progressivement je dis ça avec beaucoup
d'humilité et prudence d'une période de
pandémie est extrêmement sévère dans
notre pays sur le continent et partout
dans le monde qui a testé notre capacité
collective à réagir et coopérer et nous
allons avec en particulier la première
la nouvelle administration américaine
avoir l'occasion de ce premier sommet en
particulier de semer du g7
présidée par royaume uni puis un sommet
de l'otan
et ceci intervient quelques semaines
après le sommet sur le financement des
économies africaines que nous avons tenu
à paris ces échéances sont pour moi à la
fois l'occasion faire redémarrer la
coopération internationale sur les
grands sujets et de faire fonctionner
plusieurs engagements et cause sur
lesquels la france a investi beaucoup
depuis quatre ans et des moments aussi
de clarifications sur des sujets
importants
je voudrais concentrer mon propos autour
de quatre priorités qui ont sans doute
structuré pour beaucoup notre politique
internationale durant ces dernières
années
d'abord le multilatéralisme efficace à
travers les différents justement causé
engagements qu'il s'agisse du climat de
la santé de l'égalité du numérique ou de
la fiscalité
le deuxième axe est celui de la
souveraineté européenne le troisième
c'est celui d'une nouvelle relation avec
le continent africain est le quatrième
c'est celui de la gestion de crise
régional qui s'est depuis ces dernières
années concentrés autour de la lutte
contre le terrorisme défense de nos
valeurs et le respect de la souveraineté
de l'ensemble des états et je crois
pouvoir dire que la période actuelle va
permettre d'obtenir des résultats sur
chacun de ces actes est aussi invité des
clarifications utile premier point donc
sur lequel je voulais revenir c'est
celui du multilatéralisme efficace nous
l'avons souvent défendu durant les
quatre dernières années les pays
européens on
défendue soutenu en quelque sorte
garantie ce multilatéralisme efficace
alors que les états unis d'amérique
avait décidé de quitter donc les accords
de paris et renoncer à la coopération
dans beaucoup de domaines nous avons
porté ensemble la france il a joué son
rôle avec plusieurs initiatives et
opérations la défense de ceux
multilatéralisme et il me semble que
nous en avons posé des jalons importants
lors du g7 de barix sur les sujets de
santé de climat d'égalité sur chacun des
points biarritz avait posé des ambitions
des volontés la synthèse pourra vous en
être retourné qui sont en train de
trouver d aboutissement concret durant
ces dernières semaines derniers mois et
pour certaines vont se parachever à
l'occasion de ce de ce g7 est donc pour
moi c'est vraiment le moment je dirais
du retour de la coopération pour
permettre à ceux multilatéralisme
efficace de pleinement fonctionnelle
j'avais essayé de revenir sur chacune de
ces thématiques
la première celle de la santé évidemment
la pandémie à tester notre crédibilité
en la matière alors nous n'avons pas
attendu celle ci pour défendre ce
multilatéralisme je rappelle entre
autres que nous avions là aussi posé la
volonté de renforcer le cadre
multilatéral en matière de santé à
biarritz que nous avons en fait nous
avions à ce moment là souligné
l'importance de financer le ms et les
cadres multilatéraux et que quelques
semaines plus tard nous avons tenu à
lyon
la conférence de financement du forum
mondial qui permet justement la
vaccination et la lutte contre les
grandes pandémies en particulier sur le
continent africain
nous avions tenu nos engagements
là où à ce moment là beaucoup d'autres
avaient réduit et donc qu'il s'agisse de
lyon à l'automne 2010 9 de notre g7
nous avons ensuite poursuivie cette
multi latérale isme en matière de santé
dès le début de la crise sanitaire est à
mes yeux l'initiative la plus importante
des derniers mois a été l'initiative dit
acta
nous l'avons bâtie
avec les africains nous l'avons défendue
est portée dans le cadre du g20 et nous
avons construit une initiative dont
l'objectif était de permettre de donner
la capacité aux pays les plus pauvres en
particulier à l'afrique de résister à
l'épidémie avec des tests diagnostiques
des traitements et des vaccins avec
l'engagement de renforcer les systèmes
primaire et avec l'engagement justement
de les financer
je reviendrai sur chacun de ces points
at a poursuivi son chemin et a permis de
structurer d'initiative kovacs ce don de
vaccins est en quelque sorte arrive à un
moment de vérité lors de ce g7
c'est pourquoi sur les matières sur des
questions de santé
moelleux ce g7 est un moment de ré
engagement collectif et tarification
d'abord il nous faut définir une cible
on échange sur les sujets de vaccins
beaucoup d'objectifs et je me méfie des
objectifs quand il s'agit d'additionner
des milliards sans calendrier précis et
résultats à atteindre et je dois dire
que les échanges que j'ai pu avoir avec
les états en particulier africains
puisque je pense que ce sont les états
récipiendaires qui sont les mieux à même
de qualifier les objectifs que nous
devons nous donner m'ont convaincu qu'
il nous faut viser avant tout une cible
de pourcentage de la population à
vacciner c'est l'âge ans de crises
africaines cdc afrique a ainsi défini
60% d'africains à vacciner d'ici la fin
du premier trimestre 2011 22 avec un
objectif de 40% toute fin de l'année
2021 c'est un objectif rehaussé par
rapport à celui que nous étions engagés
à avoir dans le cadre de kovacs qui est
le véhicule par lequel la communauté
internationale
justement s'était engagé à fournir ces
vaccins qui n'était que de 20 % je pense
que c'est le bon objectif et c'est celui
que nous devons endossé dans le cadre de
ce g7 la france est prête à y prendre
toute sa part nous avons comme vous le
savez d'ores et déjà commencé à donner
des doses
nous nous sommes engagés pour cette
année est donc dit
si fin 2021 a donné 30 millions de doses
comme les allemands se sont engagés à
30/2 30 millions de doses à date ce qui
permet à l'union européenne d'avoir au
moins l'objectif de 100 millions je
pense qu'il nous faut en fonction
justement des accords revoir ses
objectifs nationaux et régionaux pour
pouvoir décaler sur ses objectifs de
vaccination est ce que je veux que la
france en dos à due proportion de sa
cote passer cet objectif de 40% de
vacciner afin d' années 60 pour cent à
la fin du premier trimestre prochain
mais d'ores et déjà nous avons effectué
à date plus de 800000 transfert de doses
ya kovacs et 1,7 million seront faits à
la fin du mois a loué à 14 pays
africains
ce dont je parle là ce ne sont pas des
engagements ce sont des livraisons déjà
effectué et et je pense que c'est
important de les rappeler 800 mille
doses déjà effectué via kovacs par la
france et 1,7 million à la fin du mois
je me réjouis que les états unis
rejoignent pleinement l'initiative et
s'engage dans cette direction et donc à
court terme
ça c'est l'objectif 40% en fin d'année
60 % fin du premier trimestre 22 de
vaccination comment y parvenir
à très court terme pour moi la priorité
doit continuer à être le don de doses
c'est la voie que nous avons décidé de
suivre
c'est celle que je veux que nous
puissions accroître dans le cadre des
discussions des prochains jours
et c'est celle qui me paraît la plus
efficace et la plus juste pour la paire
m et la renforcer
il nous faut aussi levé toutes les
restrictions à l'exportation et le g7
doit permettre de lever tous ces
obstacles
nous le savons il ya eu des
interdictions d'export de plusieurs pays
membres du g7 qui ont bloqué la
production dans d'autres pays et parfois
bloquer la production dans des pays à
revenu intermédiaire est essentielle
pour la production de vaccins à
destination des pays les plus pauvres
ça ne prend qu'un seul exemple l'inde
l'inde est en particulier le sérum
institute of india a été bloqué dans sa
production par les restrictions à
l'export d'ingrédients nécessaires à la
production de ces vaccins qui venait de
certaines économies du g7
il faut absolument les lever à la fois
pour que l'inde puisse
produire davantage pour elle même et
pour très rapidement fournir tout
particulièrement aux africains qui sont
très dépendants de sa production
ensuite nos mécanismes ne sont pas
aujourd'hui uniquement fait deux dons de
doses d'autres valeurs acheté des doses
certains veulent aussi produire pour
donner ce sera le coeur de la stratégie
américaine
toutes les stratégies sont évidemment
bonne à partir du moment où elles
permettent d'atteindre notre objectif de
vaccination et de couverture des
populations conformément à l'objectif de
l'organisation mondiale de la santé
mais nous allons défendre un point qui
me paraît essentiel sur cette affaire
c'est la transparence
aujourd'hui il n'y a pas de prix de
référence pour le mécanisme kovacs comme
pour les doses qui sont rachetés par
celui ci comme vis-à-vis des pays
récipiendaires la transparence des prix
est un élément essentiel en termes de
justice et d'efficacité
aujourd'hui nous ne savons pas à combien
kovacs achète les doses aux laboratoires
pharmaceutiques ce faisant les états
africains qui à juste titre ont décidé
aussi de compléter ces initiatives par
des achats propre achète bien souvent
deux à trois fois le prix que nous
payons nous est allé pleurer c'est une
injustice complète qu'il faut ici
corriger et donc nous devons obtenir non
pas la transparence des prix pour les
contrats qu'ils in laboratoire avec les
états les plus riches ou la communauté
internationale ça relève du droit des
affaires et nous voulons respecter mais
pour les mécanismes de solidarité
il faut une transparence des prix qui
permettra d'avoir des prix de référence
pour les états les plus pauvres pour
leur achat vient ensuite la question de
la propriété intellectuelle et elle va
jalonner en effet le parcours de notre
efficacité pourquoi parce que je pense
qu'il nous faut dès maintenant nous
organiser
j'en parlais hier avec les les ong les
plus investis sur ce sujet pour
permettre aussi aux pays les plus
pauvres et à revenu intermédiaire de
produire pour même à très court terme il
nous faut donner et produire pour donner
mais il faut au plus vite permettre aux
économies qui le peuvent de produire
pour elle même et en particulier pour
l'afrique
je crois que c'est un sujet de
considération mais c'est aussi un sujet
de l'efficacité collective
aujourd'hui l'afrique représente environ
20% des besoins en termes de vaccins
elle n'a la capacité de production que
pour 1% direction
c'est cet objectif que j'avais mis au
coeur du déplacement fait il ya quelques
semaines en particulier en afrique du
sud après le déplacement au rwanda et
nous avons d'ailleurs mené une
initiative qui va exactement en ce sens
conjointement avec l'allemagne les
etats-unis d'amérique et la banque
mondiale à travers et ses filles ce
qu'il nous faut donc faire c'est
accélérer les transferts de technologie
et la mise en capacité de tous les pays
qui le peuvent dans les régions les plus
pauvres ou à revenu intermédiaire pour
produire ça ne pourra pas couvrir les
besoins dans les six mois qui viennent
mais dans les 12 18 mois qui viennent
nous pouvons commencer sur la base de
capacités existantes à produire et
surtout c'est ce qui nous permettra de
construire notre résilience pour les
pandémies à venir nul ne sait dire les
besoins nous aurons dans le temps pour
faire face au co vide 19
parce que personne ne sait dire les
besoins en termes de rappel que nous
aurons mais à coup sûr nous aurons
d'autres pandémies et nous avons on le
sait bien d'autres vaccins à produire
sur ce sujet devant heures nous engager
à l'organisation mondiale de la santé à
l'organisation mondiale du commerce pour
garantir que la propriété intellectuelle
ne sera jamais un obstacle à l'accès au
vaccin et pour moi c'est le principe qui
doit régir notre avant la propriété
intellectuelle ne doivent jamais bloquer
ces transferts de technologie et la
capacité à produire
c'est pourquoi nous avons décidé de
mettre sur la table avec l'afrique du
sud
pour ce g7 une proposition aussi
permettant de travailler à une
dérogation limitée dans le temps et dans
l'espace de cette propriété
intellectuelle nous défendons la juste
rémunération de l'innovation et le
respect de la propriété intellectuelle
il n'y a pas de grandes innovations s'il
n'y a pas une juste rétribution de la
propriété intellectuelle mais la nature
des profits qui sont faits aujourd'hui
et leur magnitude justifie que pour les
pays qui le peuvent dans des cas d
limitée est survenu durant le pic de
l'épidémie
nous réfléchissons nous avancions et
travaillons à ces dérogations en termes
de propriété intellectuelle qui
permettront d'accélérer le transfert de
propriété et la production
c'est une proposition initiale de l'inde
et de l'afrique du sud que nous avons
retravaillé que nous souhaitons encore
travailler avec le msc nos partenaires
mais j'espère qu'elle permettra
justement un accord lors de ce g7
dans ce cadre là et pour compléter notre
réponse sur ce sujet nous défendons
également à court terme
l'idée que le don de doses c'est par les
états doit être complété par un don de
doses des laboratoires pharmaceutiques
en effet je veux ici rappeler que par le
passé nous avons défini collectivement
de tels engagements pour le secteur
privé
nous avons su en particulier lors de
l'épidémie de h1n1 définir des objectifs
de dons de doses par les laboratoires
avec un engagement à donner 10 % des
doses vendues par ailleurs c'était ce
qu'on a appelé le pandémique france
après pernez framework qui avait été
adoptée la 64e assemblée mondiale de la
santé
cet objectif nous semble
particulièrement pertinent nous vivons
évidemment une crise internationale les
états avec l'argent de nos concitoyens
de nos contribuables partout dans le
monde ont massivement financer la
recherche
l'accélération de la recherche l'achat
de nos deux doses pour nous
m l'achat de doses pour permettre de
donner il est légitime que l'industrie
pharmaceutique contribuer de manière
proportionnée sur la base de ce cadre
déjà existant à cette solidarité voilà
sur sur le sujet de la santé
les principales attentes et les
objectifs que la france défendra qui
permettent de compléter acta est d'aller
plus loin
donnez produire pour donner et permettre
aux pays les plus pauvres et à revenus
intermédiaires qui le peuvent de
produire pour romaine le deuxième grand
sujet c'est évidemment le climat sur ce
point les derniers mois ont été marqués
par le retour des états unis d'amérique
et je crois que s'élève la décision
évidemment la plus structurante pour
notre agenda international durant quatre
ans l'europe en partenariat avec la
chine à préserver le cadre de d'acteurs
de taille le retour des états unis
d'amérique marque une avancée évidemment
très structurante qui nous permet de
conforter ce cadre même s'il nous reste
énormément de travail et l'objectif est
maintenant un objectif de mise en oeuvre
et d'accélération de cette maison de
l'union européenne a pris en la matière
ces dernières ces derniers mois là aussi
des objectifs extrêmement fort en
réhaussant ses engagements pour 2030 -
55% des missions et en endossant la
neutralité carbone pour 2050 mois
d'avril dernier les états unis
d'amérique ont donné leurs propres
engagements et donc c'est sûr ce cadre
que nous allons nous réunir lors de ce
g7 pour préparer le rendez vous
important de la coop 26 de glasgow avec
quelques points auxquels nous tenons
tout particulièrement au delà évidemment
de ses objectifs est maintenant de la
mise en oeuvre à la fois des régulations
des tarification du carbone et des
investissements que chaque espace
géographique va devoir faire il nous
faudra évidemment avancé sur la finance
climat je pense que le g7 est un cadre
adapté et en particulier à la
méthodologie et aux standards en matière
de finance climatique et nous nous
défendons l'idée d'avoir une
standardisation
haddock en utilisant en particulier
l'eau c d e mais je pense que les
européens ont un rôle important à jouer
en la matière et là où nous avons
délégué historiquement les normes
comptables en anglo saxons je pense que
notre rôle historique et d'endosser la
création de normes morales pour notre
capitalisme qu'il s'agisse de normes
environnementales ou sociales
c'est un agenda que je défends depuis le
début de mon mandat que j'avais présenté
à davos il y a maintenant un peu plus de
trois ans et qui se met progressivement
en oeuvre avec en particulier celles
sujet de normalisation c'est ce que nous
avons en particulier défendu à travers
tissi f10 et nous allons faire la même
chose aussi sur la biodiversité
l'autre point évidemment c'est justement
cette attaque biodiversité nous avons la
coop vient de quang ninh
en fin d'année nous aurons luyssen à
marseille en septembre et nous
souhaitons ancrer dans le cadre du g7 la
lutte justement pour préserver la
biodiversité qui est complètement
jumelles de notre combat contre les
dérèglements climatiques
c'est le suivi à cet égard de l'eau ps
biodiversité qui s'est tenu ici même en
début de troisième grand sujet sur
lequel le multilatéralisme efficace
avance et sera consacrée lors de ce g7
c'est la régulation du numérique ce
sujet et nous aurons l'occasion à coup
sûr d'en reparler est essentiel pour nos
démocraties
nous avons vu ces dernières années le
dérèglement des esprits à l'oeuvre sur
le numérique
je vous le rappelle au printemps 2017
nous avons tout début de l'été 2010 est
lancé une initiative pour lutter contre
les contenus terroristes en ligne avec à
l'époque la première ministre et
raisonnée nous avons dans un premier
temps c'est fou que cela puisse paraître
aujourd'hui largement échoué et au nom
de la défense de la liberté d'expression
nous
nous avions été renvoyé en quelque sorte
dans nos propres terrains de jeu les
choses ont avancé malheureusement et
après le terrible attentat de
christchurch en nouvelle-zélande au
printemps 2010 9 nous avons tenu ici
même à l'elysée en mai 2019
une réunion appelée l'appel de cry surf
qui a permis de réunir plusieurs
gouvernements des grandes industries de
la technologie des réseaux sociaux pour
mettre en place un premier cadre
innovant dans lequel nous nous sommes
engagés au retrait en 1h02 contenu
terroristes prenant le terrorisme mais
aussi dans une méthode de coopération
entre les états les acteurs du numérique
cette méthode a eu des résultats nous
avons eu des résultats concrets parce
que toutes les plateformes qui l'ont
signée s'y sont conformés j'en veux pour
preuve ce que d'ailleurs la france a eu
à vivre à l'automne dernier lorsque nous
avons eu à subir des attentats ce sont
les plateformes qui nous les ont signalé
qu'ils ont retiré ses contenus en
premier dans leur surtout l'europe est
venu compléter cette avancée puisque
nous avons passé des texte juridiquement
contraignant qui maintenant mettre dans
notre droit
l'obligation de retirer en une heure ces
contenus terroristes
il nous faut maintenant aller plus loin
à deux égards le premier c'est d'élargir
les pays membres de cet appel et à ce
titre en mai dernier nous avons une
avancée substantielle puisque les états
unis d'amérique ont acté lors décision
de rejoindre l'appel de christchurch
ce qui évidemment compte tenu du nombre
d'entreprises présentes de sa
l'américain est incorporé aux états unis
d'amérique est un élément transformant
et je m'en réjouis
la deuxième chose c'est d'avancer pour
créer le cadre qui permettra aussi
efficacement que nous l'avons fait pour
le terrorisme de lutter contre tous les
discours de haine en ligne discours
raciste discours antisémite et tous les
discours aussi de harcèlement vous savez
que nous avons poursuivi en franco
français cet agenda et nous allons donc
jusqu'au bout nous souhaitons le
poursuivre au niveau européen à travers
les directives qui ont été proposées en
fin d'année dernière par la commission
qui sont le fruit de cet agenda de
christchurch
nous souhaitons aussi que dans le cadre
international il y a un engagement du g7
à aller dans cette direction c'est ce
que nous portons pour véritablement
avoir un multilatéralisme efficace en
termes de régulation de l'internet et de
ses comptes
c'est la seule condition pour avoir un
cadre efficace que nous porterons
ensuite en g20 qui permet de lutter
contre un an sauvagement des esprits et
de la communication est donc un ans
sauvagement de notre nouvel ordre public
mondial
les algorithmes sont en particulier un
élément essentiel que nous devons viser
dans ces régulations
c'est à la fois un cadre coopératif avec
ses réseaux et ses grands groupes ces
grandes plateformes mais nous avançons
aussi toujours en même temps sur un
cadre plus contraignant puisque nous
passons des législations nationales et
européennes pour le complet cette
initiative est la clé pour éviter nous
pourrons y revenir si vous souhaitez
dans les questions une fragmentation
l'internet mondial parce que ce qui se
joue c'est notre capacité à réguler
l'internet mondial le risque sinon étant
que des régulations de fait s'impose à
nous qu'ils soient structurées autour
des préférences chinoise d'une part et
des préférences américaines de l'autre
ce pourquoi nous nous battons là c'est
défendre nos valeurs celles sont
précisément au coeur du multilatéralisme
et de l'universalisme bâti dans la
deuxième moitié du xxème quatrième sujet
essentiel de ce multilatéralisme
efficace qui est presque la poursuite de
ce que je viens de dire
c'est la fiscalité internationale vous
savez depuis quatre ans la france se bat
pour que nous corrigions une injustice
profonde de notre organisation
internationale le fait que des grands
groupes qui font des surprofits parce
qu'ils arrivent à optimiser grâce à la
numérisation de leurs activités en
particulier ne paient pas leur juste
part d'impôts c'est inexplicable pour
nos contribuables et nos concitoyens
c'est injuste pour nos entreprises
en particulier les pme les tpe qui elles
payent l'impôt alors qu'elles sont
parfois sur le même secteur
cet agenda nous n'avons porté nous nous
sommes battus pour halo cdo d'abord et
cet agenda
quel que soit le travail remarquable que
l'osce et de et ses équipes ont mené
depuis le début je veux ici les saluer a
été bloqué par l'administration
américaine
durant les quatre dernières années nous
avons ensuite décidé de le porter au
niveau européen et il est lui-même en
quelque sorte attendu les avancées de le
céder et donc à quelques états membres
nous avons décidé de mettre en oeuvre
nos taxes numérique pour aller de
l'avant
ce qu'a fait la france et ce qu'elle a
assumée et au moment où nous sommes en
train de vivre une avancée je veux ici
quand même le dire le rôle que nous
avons joué et surtout le rôle que
certains secteurs économiques français
ont joué qui ont été en quelque sorte
les victimes des représailles
et au moment où nous sommes en train
d'enregistrer une victoire pour cette
taxe internationale
j'ai une pensée pour nos viticulteurs et
beaucoup d'entreprises parfois modestes
qui durant les deux dernières années ont
payé les sanctions de la rétorsion
américaine parce que nous avions mis en
place une taxe numérique c'est comme ça
que ça s'est passé
ne l'oublions pas et eux des gens pour
être contre il ya eu des gens pour
avancer caché
je me félicite que nous n'ayons pas
avancer caché pour ce qui nous concerne
et que certains secteurs économiques en
en payer le prix et je les en remercie
parce qu'ils ont été en quelque sorte
les victimes collatérales de notre sens
des responsabilités
c'est pourquoi ils étaient ses dires est
évident nous attendons maintenant
uniquement la date que nous aurons
toutes les assurances pour que de telles
taxes ne réserve pas je crois qu'il n'y
a plus de 200 scène constitue alité
commercial puisque nous sommes tous
d'accord et que nous allons enfin
pouvoir mettre en place cette juste
taxation qui se construit autour de deux
piliers comme vous le savez l'un qui
permet d'accéder sur profits et donc en
particulier ceux des grands groupes
eric et le deuxième qui permet de mettre
en place un impôt minimal d'au moins 15%
ce qui évite l'optimisation fiscale pour
les grands groupes
les derniers détails techniques
viendront dans les semaines qui viennent
mais c'est pour l'économie française
quelque chose qui tournera entre 5 et 10
milliards d'euros sans doute et pour les
économies européennes quelque chose qui
tombera autour de 50 milliards d'euros
et donc vous voyez l'importance de ces
avancées qui seront réelles autour de
donc il ne faut pas mollir mais
l'injustice fiscale permet aussi d'avoir
plus d'efficacité est en quelque sorte
d'alléger la charge d'autres
contribuables
cet accord a été consacrée au niveau des
ministres des finances du g7
nous allons l'endosser au niveau des
chefs d'état et de gouvernement début
juillet il sera portée dans le cadre du
g20 et il sera parachevé dans un cadre
inclusif qui est celui de 139 et a
piloté par l' ocde
parce qu'évidemment une telle taxation
et efficace s'il n'y a pas de point de
fuite et de paradis fiscaux qui se tient
hors de ce cadre
mais ce faisant nous allons parachever
un travail qui a commencé depuis la
crise financière de 2008 2010 qui avait
permis de mettre fin au secret bancaire
puis de mettre fin aux mécanismes
d'évasion fiscale par érosion des bases
fiscales et donc c'est une avancée
massive pour une mondialisation plus
efficace et plus juste
dernier point en matière de
multilatéralisme efficace c'est
justement la lutte contre les inégalités
pandémie a fortement accru ses
inégalités
et donc nous devons nous engager pour là
aussi renforcer nos propres
investissements en la matière la france
comme vous le savez est en train de
voter une trajectoire qui réhausse son
aide publique au développement à très
court terme de 0 5% 0 points 55 % de
notre production nationale et nous le
porterons ensuite à 0 7%
mais enfin ce faisant à plus d'une
décade de décrue ou stabilisation de
publique au développement et au coeur de
cette lutte contre les inégalités nous
souhaitons porter comme nous le faisons
là aussi depuis quatre ans la lutte
contre les inégalités de genre nous
l'avions mis au coeur du g7 de biarritz
et le g7 de biarritz a permis des
avancées concrètes je veux en citer deux
le mécanisme de financement pour
l'entreprenariat féminin
nous avions lancé à biarritz 10 à faua
porté par la banque africaine de
développement et angélique kidjo a
permis de lever un milliard d'euros de
financements pour des projets
d'entrepreneuriat féminin
partout en afrique de la même manière
nous avions lancé le bouquet législatif
poussant chacun des états membres à
prendre des législations comme
d'ailleurs nous sommes en train de le
faire nous l'avons fait en france il a
permis d'avancer dans tout quatorze pays
partenaires pour prendre des
législations favorables à l'égalité
femmes-hommes qu'il s'agisse d'égalité
salariale ou d'égalité statutaire nous
souhaitons poursuivre évidemment ces
avancées à l'occasion de ce g7
en particulier nous prendrons des
engagements pour leur financement du
partenariat mondial pour l'éducation que
nous avions coprésider il y a maintenant
trois ans avec le le sénégal pour la
conférence de refinancement et nous
fêterons 50% du financement pour
l'éducation des jeunes filles
je lui dis parce que c'est un combat que
nous menons là aussi depuis le début
avec quelques autres mais en matière de
lutte contre les inégalités
l'investissement dans l'éducation des
jeunes filles tout particulièrement sur
le continent africain est essentielle
elle a reculé ces derniers mois à cause
de la pandémie et à cause des conflits
qui se passe dans toute la région
donc nous accroîtrons notre engagement
en l'oeuf les champs sur l'éducation des
jeunes filles
l'autre point c'est évidemment que nous
préparons le travail à destination du
forum génération égalité que nous co
président avec le mexique et onu femmes
et qui se tiendra ici même dans les
derniers jours de juin le premier jour
juillet et qui permettra là aussi 25 ans
après pékin est bien de nous battre pour
préserver les droits des femmes partout
dans le monde et y compris dans des
régions qui sont les plus proches de
notre pays où ces droits sont bien
souvent menacés qu'il s'agisse du droit
des femmes à disposer de leur corps ou
qu'il s'agit simplement de droit à avoir
une juste place dans la société
aux confins de l'europe ces droits sont
aujourd'hui remises en cause et ce
rendez-vous sera absolument essentiel à
cet égard voilà le principal est le
premier point que je vous sur lequel je
voulais revenir ce sommet du g7
comme vous le voyez point d'orgue en
quelque sorte des derniers mois 7 pour
nous grâce au retour l'administration
américaine qui partagent l'essentiel de
nos convictions
grâce aussi au travail que nous avons
fait ces quatre dernières années la
possibilité d'avoir des des vrais
résultats
en complément tout ce que nous avons
poursuivi ces derniers
deuxième grand axe et je serai jouera
sur beaucoup plus rapide qui est pour
moi au coeur de ces jours à venir c'est
celui de la souveraineté européenne mais
souvent entendu défendre ce concept
qu'elle je crois profondément
celle d'une union européenne qui a
besoin de construire le cadre de son
autonomie stratégique en matière
économique industrielle technologique de
valeur militaire
nous avons un solide bilan à cet égard
ces dernières années en europe de la
défense qui a avancé comme elle
n'avançait plus depuis les années 50
des coopérations renforcées un fonds
européen de défense des projets communs
en particulier franco-allemand nous
avons élargi à quelques autres
partenaires qui ces dernières semaines
ont connu des avancées massive
nous avons réussi a présidé un réveil en
termes de souveraineté technologique sur
la 5g mais aussi sur les composants
essentiels avec une commission qui est
porte beaucoup plus cet agenda et en
particulier sur le plan d'ailleurs
numérique
les directives des mads et nous avons
bâti ou souveraineté économique et
financière durant la crise inédite en
particulier grâce à l'initiative germano
française de mai 2020 puis au sommet de
juillet qui a permis de bâtir une
capacité d'endettement commune et un
plan d'investissement inédit cela de
nous arrivons à ce g7 et ce sommet de
l'otan avec tout cet héritage est pour
moi le premier objectif c'est que nos
partenaires reconnaissent cette nouvelle
donne européenne et que nous sachions
bâtir un nouveau partenariat avec les
états unis d'amérique partenariat de
valeur alliance sur certains sujets mais
aussi partenariat lucide qui consiste à
dire que notre voisinage c'est à nous de
le gérer parce que nous avons aussi
appris l'histoire collectivement et de
tout particulièrement l'histoire des 20
dernières années
et c'est dans cet esprit que j'aborde
justement ce g7 et ce sommet de l'otan
je me félicite du réengagement américain
dans le concert des nations
et dans cette ce multi latérale isme
coopératif est pour moi la clé c'est que
les européens restent unis et attentifs
à leur souveraineté commune et c'est que
nous puissions avoir aussi notre voie
communauté de valeurs mais indépendance
quand il s'agit de notre stratégie à
l'égard de la chine indépendance quand
il s'agit de notre stratégie à l'égard
de nos voisins qu'il s'agisse de la
russie ou la turquie responsabilités
quand il s'agit de gérer nos voisinages
les balkans la méditerranée le continent
afrique
à ce titre trois choses sont à mes yeux
essentielles pour sommet de l'otan qui
vient premier c'est que précisément ses
efforts cette consolidation soit
respectée dans le dialogue et que donc
l'autonomie stratégique capacitaire des
européens soit reconnue la france a en
2020 investi 2% de son produit intérieur
brut
dans sa défense et les sujets minutes la
deuxième chose c'est que nous mettions
en oeuvre le rapport des sages
là aussi je
l'esprit de responsabilité et de
continuité je faisais le suivi du g7 de
biarritz de l'été 2010 9 faut faire le
suivi du sommet 2019 est en quelque
sorte de cette semaine la larme que
j'avais tiré au sujet de l'otan il ya eu
un rapport des sages
qu'est ce qu'il dit l'otan doit
clarifier ces valeurs communes
le temps doit bâtir une règle de
conduite entre alliés et le temps doit
clarifier son concept il sera scandée
par le travail de boussole stratégique
sous présidence française de l'union
européenne puis quelques mois plus tard
la clarification de la finalisation du
concept otaniens par l'ensemble de ses
membres
bien je pense que ce rendez vous lundi
prochain doit être l'occasion justement
de consacrer cet agenda l'avancé le fait
que l'otan doit bien clarifiée quel est
son rôle et sa stratégie
à cet égard et surtout ancrer cet apport
du rapport des sages c'est à dire les
règles de conduite entre états membres
et le troisième point qui me paraît très
important dans ce contexte c'est que
nous assumions nous européens d'être les
acteurs de la maîtrise des armements sur
notre sol je pense que c'est un sujet
essentiel pour les mois et les années
qui viennent
le traité effet ni ayant été dénoncé par
les états unis d'amérique de lune 19 non
respectés par la russie nous ne pouvons
pas accepter de revenir à une grammaire
qui serait celle de la guerre froide
l'europe n'est pas simplement un objet
ou un territoire de la répartition des
influences nous sommes un sujet de la
géopolitique internationale et nous
devons l'assumer
les européens ont donc à décider pour
eux-mêmes de la méprise
désarmement qui les concerne la france
en tant que puissance d'opter membres
permanents du conseil de sécurité et qui
assume d'être une puissance dotée car
investi dans la composante nucléaire
entend bien porter justement ses valeurs
sa place dans ce dialogue troisième axe
les prochains jours c'est cette nouvelle
relation avec l'afrique et le new deal
avec là je serai très rapide sur ce
point mais il m'importe parce qu'il est
aussi le fil rouge de ce que nous
faisons depuis le début du discours de
ouagadougou du g7 présidé par la france
où nous avons pour la première fois
associés les états africains la
construction de notre propre agenda
ils étaient partie prenante de ce g7
jusqu'à acta que nous avons bâtie avec
les africains et aux initiatives pour le
25 nous construisons ensemble
j'arriverai à ce g7 avec la même
conviction
là aussi les africains honte à être
partie prenante des ambitions que la
communauté internationale a à leur égard
et c'est essentiel c'est pour ça que
pour les vaccins
je considère que nous devons prendre les
objectifs de l'union africaine et de
l'afrique et nous devons avancer sur cet
agenda avec le coeur au delà de ce que
j'ai déjà dit en matière de santé
ce que nous voulons porter pour
l'afrique est en matière de financement
des économies africaines et de faire le
suivi du sommet de paris
pourquoi parce que si l'afrique a vécu
un choc sanitaires comme nous tous elle
a vécu un choc économique d'une ampleur
inédite
les fermetures d'économie la fermeture
du commerce international les
restrictions ont un impact le continent
africain sans égale par rapport aux et
les économies africaines n'ont
évidemment pas nos capacités budgétaires
mais elles n'ont pas non plus nos
instruments monétaires tout les grands
espaces économiques du monde ont joué
avec une politique monétaire extrêmement
accommodante durant cette période la
chine avec son propre système
les états unis avec la fed et la zone
euro avec la b c l'afrique n'a
ces mécanismes et donc les besoins de
financement créé par la crise qu vides
sont au bas mot 2 290 milliards de
dollars entre aujourd'hui et 2020 100 et
je dis bien au ballon
ce n'est pas qu'un esprit de solidarité
c'est un devoir aussi d'efficacité comme
pour le vaccin l'afrique est le
continent le plus jeune du monde 70 % de
sa population à moins qu'un exemple
c'est un continent qui chaque année
accroît sa part dans la population
internationale
il représentera demi d'ici 2050 au bas
mot un quart de celle ci de cette
population sur toute sa jeunesse
si nous laissons l'afrique face à ses
besoins de financement nous prendrions
la même responsabilité que nous allions
priso sortie de la deuxième guerre
mondiale
en laissant l'europe face à ses dettes
c'est un élément de lucidité de la
communauté internationale et en
particulier des européens dans le moment
nous parlons d'aider l'afrique de
l'aider pour elle-même et de l'aider
pour nous mêmes parce que nous devons
changer cette relation ne plus avoir une
relation de défiance de sécurité de
migration subi mais permettre aux
économies africaines de bâtir l'avenir
de leur jeunesse en leur redonnant les
leviers à très court terme ceci passe
par un investissement massif dans les
économies du continent africain nous
avons plaidé depuis novembre de l'année
dernière lors du forum mondial de paris
pour la paix pour une émission
exceptionnelle de droits de tirage
spéciaux du fonds monétaire
international qu'est ce que c'est c'est
une augmentation de capital du fonds
monétaire international qui en quelque
sorte vos création monétaire pour les
économies qui en sont action
l'administration américaine nouvelle a
soutenu ce projet nous sommes nous avons
donc bâti un accord pour avoir 650
milliards de droits de tirage spéciaux
résultat historique
si les clés de répartition du fmi sont
mécaniquement appliquer ceux ci ne
représentent que 33 milliards pour
l'afrique dont 24 milliards pour
l'afrique subsaharienne
c'est à dire un dixième du besoin pour
ce faire il nous faut nous pays les plus
riches réallouer nos droits de tirage
spéciaux pour les leur province c'est la
pseudo solide la france s'est engagée
lors du sommet de paris à le faire pour
qu'il y ait au moins 100 milliards
qu'ils aillent vers des africains la
vérité c'est qu'il nous faudrait viser
150 et donc nous ferons le maximum pour
avoir ce consensus ça suppose que nous
ayons l'accord évidemment des états unis
d'amérique et la décision du congrès et
du reste de nos partenaires européens
le rendez vous du g7 doit permettre
d'obtenir cet accord historique avec
comme objectif d'avoir au moins 100
milliards de droits de tirage spéciaux
qui vont vers la ferme
c'est un des buts et 106 ce mécanisme
devrait être complétée par un accord
pour vendre aussi une partie de nos
réserves d'or et finances mais financer
ses investissements
pourquoi parce que les réserves d'or du
fmi ont augmenté en valeur au bénéfice
de la crise parce que l'heure a été une
valeur refuge
utilisons ce surprofits pour le
justement le donner aux pays les plus
pauvres en particulier africains qui en
ont aujourd'hui besoin pas dans 20 ans
ou 30 ans aujourd'hui
troisième point nous devons aussi oeuvré
pour permettre aux banques régionales
africaines d'utiliser ces droits de
tirage spéciaux ce qui leur permettra
d'avoir un effet de levier et d'être des
vrais partenaires de leur développement
nous défendons le fait que l'union
africaine la banque africaine de
développement
les autres banques régionales puissent
bénéficier de ses droits de tirage
spéciaux et les utiliser pour faire
davantage de dons et prêts à leur
économie
enfin nous portons de compléter cette
initiative par deux éléments le premier
un investissement massif du secteur
privé c'est pour ça que nous avons
lancée l'alliance justement pour
l'entreprenariat et l'investissement
privé en lien avec
la ffii il ya le groupe banque mondiale
et d'autre part par la reconstruction du
cadre budgétaire et financier
international du fmi et de la banque
mondiale les règles aujourd'hui de
déficit de suivi du déficit et de
réformes du fmi doivent être retravaillé
en partenariat avec les états
récipiendaires
là aussi par respect par cohérence
toutes les économies du monde ont revu
leurs dogmes ne budgétaire nous mêmes
européens avant lever les contraintes
que nous nous étions imposés à nous
mêmes il y a près de 30 ans pourquoi
continuer à imposer le même cadre aux
économies africaines
alors que leur défi est encore plus
grand que le nôtre compte tenu de leur
réalité démographique il faut repenser
ce cadre est acceptée en tant que jeune
économies du g7 de porter cette action
enfin et je m'arrêterai sur ce point la
gestion des crises je ne les couvrirait
pas tout et je répondrai à vos questions
pour toutes celles que je n'aurais pas
évoqué mais parlant de gestion des
crises je veux là aussi poursuivre et
conclure sur l'afrique la gestion des
crises pour ce qui nous concerne depuis
quatre ans a consisté à suivre quelques
fils rouges d'abord nous engager partout
où il fallait lutter contre le
terrorisme international et en
particulier le terrorisme islamiste
parce que nous avons été touchés sur
notre sol et parce qu'il déstabilise les
déstabilise des résumés régions voisines
et amies le proche et moyen-orient
depuis trop d'années avec la question
évidemment de notre implication dans le
cadre de la coalition
en zone irak au ciel mais aussi avec le
dossier iranien et d'autre part
l'afrique puisque l'épicentre
aujourd'hui du terrorisme international
s'est déplacé en afrique durant les deux
dernières années
deuxième principe qui nous a toujours
guidé c'est de défendre nos valeurs
et là aussi partout d'intervenir
devrait pour que les valeurs que nous
défendons dans le cadre international
soit promu défendu respecter une
troisième principe c'est de respecter la
souveraineté des états c'est une
grammaire à laquelle je crois vous
m'avez aussi souvent entendu le dire je
ne pense pas qu'on puisse se substituer
à un peuple souverain pour construire
son bien à la place de lui même on peut
influencer on peut vraiment peuvent
durcir avec les gouvernements
je ne crois pas à une politique qui
consiste à se substituer à lui c'est
d'ailleurs ainsi que nous avons
constamment oeuvré pour proche et
moyen-orient comme on l'a fait en la
matière comme vous le savez la france
est engagée depuis maintenant un peu
plus de huit ans auxerre après
l'intervention salutaire décidée par le
président hollande au mali qui a permis
de sauver bamako et de stopper la
déstabilisation de l'état malien à la
demande de celui-ci la cedeao de nous
sommes ensuite installée à la demande
des états souverains de la région et de
la cedeao dans une opération dite barkan
de longue durée qui a structuré la
protection de ces états contre le
terrorisme
justement islamistes dans toute la
région la menace contre leur
souveraineté étatique
beaucoup de nos soldats sont tombés et
en vous disant ça j'ai une pensée
profonde pour eux pour leur famille
n'est pas ce que nous leur devons la
cohérence la poursuite de la mission
jusqu'au bout et la clarté à l'égard de
nos missions j'ai l'occasion de
repréciser le cadre de notre
intervention lors du sommet de pau début
de l'année 2020 de faire le suivi de
celui ci au début de cette année
n'djamena et nous arrivons aujourd'hui à
un moment qui impose de mettre en oeuvre
ce que j'avais commencé à définir impôts
ce que nous avions conçu en fin d'année
dernière et que j'avais partagé avec nos
partenaires parce que le temps est venu
la poursuite de notre engagement au
sahel ne se fera pas à cadre constants
nous allons
avec nos partenaires engagés à nos côtés
mais aussi avec les pays de la région
parce que j'ai toujours eu ce souci de
les associer de travailler avec eux
tirer les enseignements de ce qui a
fonctionné notamment les évolutions que
nous avions un pull c'est justement à
pau puis n'djamena mais tirait aussi les
enseignements de ce qui n'a pas
fonctionné
la présence durable dans le cadre
d'opérations extérieures de la france ne
peut pas se substituer au retour de
l'état et des services de l'état à la
stabilité politique et au choix des
états souverains
nous ne pouvons pas sécuriser des zones
qui retombe dans l'anomie parce que des
états décident de ne pas prendre leurs
responsabilités c'est impossible ou
alors c'est un travail sans fin
c'est pourquoi à l'issue de
consultations que nous conduirons avec
nos partenaires en particulier nos
partenaires américains qui joue un rôle
essentiel
depuis le début et je veux ici les en
remercier et nos partenaires européens
qui sont aussi à nos côtés en
particulier dans le cadre de utm
nous amorcerons une transformation
profonde de notre présence militaire au
sahel dont les modalités et le
calendrier seront précisées dans les
semaines à venir je le ferai d'ici à la
fin du mois de juin mais je vais initié
ce travail dès les jours prochains
cette transformation se traduira par un
changement de modèle il impliquera le
passage à un nouveau cadre
c'est à dire la fin de l'opération
barkan en tant qu'opération extérieur
pour permettre une opération d'appui de
soutien et de coopération aux armées des
pays de la région qui le souhaitent et
de la mise en oeuvre d'une opération
militaire et d'une alliance
internationale associant les états de la
région et tous nos partenaires
strictement concentrer sur la lutte
contre le terrorisme
ce nouveau cadre préservera nos
engagements auprès de nos partenaires
engagés à nos côtés dans la force
takouba et dans l'opération le ytn qui
devront
suivre leur montée en puissance une tn
sera un des éléments de la formation de
toutes les armées partenaires et takouba
sera le pilier de cette force de lutte
contre le terrorisme
les armées françaises en seront
évidemment la colonne vertébrale mais
elles seront complétées par les forces
spéciales des armées de la région
partenaire qui le souhaiteront et le
pont est évidemment par les forces
spéciales de nos partenaires européens
beaucoup d'entre eux s'étant déjà
engagés à nos côtés dans ce cadre ces
évolutions nous allons les travailler
dans les prochaines semaines elles
seront présentées dans le cadre de la
coalition pour le sahel que nous avons
mises en place lors du sommet de
n'djamena et qui se réunira justement
très prochainement j'aurai à les
présenter dans le détail la fin du mois
de juin voilà les quelques éléments que
je souhaitais partager avec vous avant
maintenant deux répondra à toutes vos
questions
c'est moi qui distribue la parole c'est
mais je peux le faire c'est faire comme
ça vous en fait bonjour monsieur le
président ici au fond il ya un micro qui
circulent alors veillez bien ce que tout
le monde puisse avoir
vous en prie sylvie corbet associati de
presse vous avez mancier mentionné à
plusieurs reprises le retour de
l'administration américaine
le président by john a annoncé
aujourd'hui le don de 500 millions de
doses de vaccins supplémentaires pour
les pays les plus pauvres et
l'administration américaine appelle
aujourd'hui les autres pays du g7 à en
faire davantage
est-ce que vous n'approuvez pas une
certaine frustration à voir que les
etats-unis mènent désormais la les
discussions sur ce sujet et peut-être
veulent imposer leur terme
alors que la france a été le premier
pays à faire un don à kovacs et est ce
que la france elle même est prête à
annoncer un don supplémentaire pendant
ce sommet du g7 n'ont d'abord je pense
que c'est une très bonne nouvelle parce
que rappelez vous il y a un an vous me
disiez est-ce que vous n'êtes pas
frustré a proposé des choses qui
n'avance jamais parce que les américains
ne croient plus au multilatéralisme
donc je vous dis juste la période
récompense la ténacité
ensuite je suis lucide sur la taille des
économies que nous représentons les uns
les autres
je pense qu'il faut au contraire qui est
une émulation en terme d'ambition c'est
une très bonne chose et moi je me
réjouis de cette annonce américaine qui
est tout à fait positive
je pense maintenant qu'il faut qu'on se
touche très précis en terme d'agenda
si ces 500 millions de doses d'ici la
fin de l'année 2021 c'est une formidable
nouvelle
et je pense que l'union européenne doit
match et cette annonce et nous nous
organiserons si ces 500 millions de
doses d'ici mi 2011 22 ça n'est déjà pas
la même nature et je pense qu'ils font
au moins on fasse pareil donc il faut
préciser les calendriers vous savez
j'étais en afrique il ya quinze jours
premier ministre était en tunisie avec
une partie du gouvernement il ya
quelques jours ils croient plus à nos
engagements en chiffre en milliards ou
autres qui croient dans les doses qui
arrivent sur le terrain et donc
je moi je porterais modestement cette
voie combien et quand et donc je pense
que l'union européenne doit au moins
justement être au même niveau d'ambition
que ce que les états unis viennent de
dire mais il faut que vis-à-vis de nos
partenaires
on car ici le calendrier très
précisément et qu'on dise quand on livre
des doses et je dirais que c'est presque
plus important de dire combien on en
livres le mois prochain que de promettre
monts et merveilles dans 18 mois ou dans
un an et il faut vraiment pas qu'on
perde de vue de ce point donc je pense
est une très très bonne nouvelle
il faut avancer et je pense que si les
américains portent la levée des
restrictions sur les exports qu'ils
avaient imposées c'est une nouvelle qui
est au moins aussi importante parce
qu'elle va permettre l'un de produire
des milliards de doses là aussi pour
l'année prochaine et donc c'est un
ensemble
mais je me félicite de cette annonce
mais qu'at il à vis d'elle la francofête
à nous rejoindre sur le président vous
avez pointé déjà là là l'importance de
la relation franco allemande
ce sera le dernier g7 comme le dernier
sommet de l'otan pour madame merkel est
ce que vous craignez que son départ crée
une sorte d équilibre et notamment en
vue du changement d'opérations au mali
que vous annoncez est ce que vous
risquez avec la nouvelle allemagne de ne
plus avoir un partenaire ainsi présents
au sahel
écoutez d'abord j'aurai une certaine
émotion à vivre ce dernier sommet du g7
ce motant avec angela merkel avec qui
nous avons d'abord bâti une amitié
personnelle et ensuite bâti une relation
de travail d'efficacité de confiance et
nous avons su chacun je dirais sortir
des habitudes et je pense que fameux
couple franco-allemand germaneau
français à avancer parce que nous
n'avons pas été n'avons jamais été les
caricatures demain
j'ai confiance d'abord dans la solidité
la force de la politique allemande des
dernières années et le caractère je
dirais tendancielle est un peu
inéluctable de ce qui a été commencé
ensuite je pense que les choix profondes
du peuple allemand
quelles que soient les sensibilités qui
arrive aux responsabilités permettra de
continuer à avancer sur notre ambition
européenne sur notre ambition en matière
de défense sur notre ambition
internationale et en vous annonçant ici
les transformations qui seront à
l'oeuvre au sel j'ai pris le soin de
dire que
nous tiendrons tous les engagements pris
à l'égard de nos partenaires européens
et donc je pense que ce changement n'est
pas de nature pour nos partenaires à
reconsidérer l'engagement qui est le
leur dans le cadre de la minustah dans
le cadre de utm dans le cadre de taku de
takouba et c'est très important je crois
à la force de la continuité
une ambition renouvelée il y aura une
équipe qui sera gardé le meilleur et qui
nous poussera collectivement à faire
encore mieux plutôt comme ça que je vois
les choses
je vous précise isabelle lasserre du
figaro en novembre 2019 juste avant le
précédent sommet de moto vous aviez
évoqué la mort cérébrale de l'alliance
j'ai bien noté que vous avez parlé de du
rapport des sages et de tout le travail
qui s'éteignent en marche
mais aujourd'hui je vous pose la
question à nouveau est ce que
aujourd'hui précisément aujourd'hui loto
est toujours en état de mort cérébrale
je pense que l'otan aujourd'hui est dans
une situation qui nécessite une très
grande clarification stratégique
oui je pense que la nouvelle
administration américaine nous permettra
d'avoir un sommet qui sera aussi celui
d'une forme de deux d'apaisement sur
beaucoup de sujets il n'en demeure pas
moins que nous avons besoin de clarifier
stratégiquement à plusieurs égards
où va l'organisation transatlantique
premièrement quelle relation
voulons-nous avec la russie je me
félicite qu'un sommet se prépare entre
les deux présidents avec éthique
personnelle j'ai toujours prôné le
dialogue
je m'étonne parfois que ceux qui
trouvent que la france a tort de
dialoguer disent que les états unis ont
raison de dialoguer mais parfois des
choses qui m'échappent nomazy tout cas
je pense que l'organisation a besoin de
construire un cadre apaisé avec la
russie exigeant intraitable lorsqu'il ya
des incursions des cyberattaques des
intimidations
mais ils permettent aussi prendre en
compte ce qu'est la géographique
l'europe
l'organisation a besoin de clarifier un
cadre en terme de
désarmement n'avons pas aujourd'hui on a
besoin de dire qui est notre ennemi et
où est à cet égard nous aurons un
éléphant dans la pièce la situation
afghane et la décision qui a pris qui
met un terme à vingt ans d'engagement et
qui quoi qu'on en dise a été un
changement rapide qui a déstabilisé
certains alliés je le dis d'autant plus
humblement que comme vous savez la
france n'était pas de loin le pays le
plus engagé mais je pense que nous avons
besoin de nous répartir les rôles
quelles sont nos valeurs
comment gérer notre voisinage et donc
quelle politique à l'égard de la russie
quelle politique à l'égard du proche et
moyen-orient quelle politique à l'égard
du continent africain pour lutter contre
le terrorisme
deuxième grande question stratégique ce
sera
quid de la chine pour ma part la chine
c'est à partie de la géographie
atlantique
ou alors la carte à un problème donc je
considère que c'est pas le coeur du
sujet mais vous voyez bien que l'on a
sur beaucoup de sujets une espèce de
vague stratégie qui ne sait plus le
temps a été construit pour faire face au
pacte de varsovie cas elle s'est
structurée idéologiquement dans ce face
à face il n'est plus parce qu'il faut
très clairement clarifier notre cadre
d'intervention requalifier les éléments
de solidarité moi je respecte totalement
que les états unis d'amérique décide de
ne plus être autant engagés qu'ils
l'étaient pendant les décennies
précédentes au proche et moyen-orient
on a besoin de ce débat clair et dans
ces cas là de dire c'est l'europe qui
s'y engagent bien davantage sur quelles
lignes comment je pense que simplement
il faut avoir ce dialogue de vérité
et puis je pense que nous avons besoin
de poser le cadre clair de nos relations
entre amis les contraintes en termes de
désengagement et surtout le respect des
alliés en termes d'équipement mais aussi
en terme d'intervention c'est aussi pour
ça que j'aurais une rencontre avec le
président erdogan
juste avant le sommet de l'otan parce
que je considère que cette clarification
c'est tout particulièrement avec la
turquie elle doit se faire dans le
respect d'exigences
mais quand on est membre de la même
organisation on peut pas décider de
prendre des équipements qui ne
permettent pas l'interopérabilité on ne
peut pas décider de mener des opérations
unilatérales qui sont contraires aux
intérêts des coalitions qu'on a bâtie
donc voyez il ya des incohérences qu'on
n'a pas réglé il y a parfois des
précipitations que nous n'avons pas
coordonnées il ya surtout une
réorganisation stratégique de où sont
nos menaces
comment gérer notre voisinage qui nous
faut clarifier pour moi il faut en
discuter lors de ce sommet mais il sera
très rapide mais il faut surtout bâtir
les prochains mois de travail la
boussole stratégique sous présidence
française de l'union européenne et le
nouveau concept de l'alliance qui
viendra dans la foulée je n'ai aucun
pouvoir c'est une panique au jour ce
président et chef des verts
la chaîne arabia vous avez évoqué
rapidement le dossier iranien à ce que
ce dossier iranien sera évoqué sera
abordé au g7 et quel regard portez-vous
sur le rôle de l'iran au proche-orient
en syrie en irak au yémen et au liban le
liban qui attend toujours
il attend toujours votre visite le liban
merci lit et dennis asus parmi vous ce
sujet et
je distingue toujours le peuple des
régimes je dis ici parce qu'on a
beaucoup parlé durant ces dernières
années le peuple iranien importune une
culture propre et du dirait une richesse
dans la région qui sont des véritables
trésors
et il ne faut pas l'oublier simplement
le régime iranien aujourd'hui est une
menace pour les équilibres de la région
il est une menace en raison du programme
nucléaire
et là dessus je tiens la même position
que depuis 2010 est c'est à dire que
nous avons besoin de retrouver un cadre
multilatéral qui permet seul le contrôle
on l'a perdu et nous avons besoin de
renforcer justement ces contrôles et
l'exigence pour que l'iran ne puisse pas
se doter de l'armé nucléaire
mais la menace iranienne ne se réduit
pas à cela c'est aussi menaçante à en
tant que puissance régionale par ses
capacités balistiques pour tous les
états de la région et donc nous devons
dans le cadre d'un dialogue qui est à
exigeant qui est à rebâtir prendre en
compte ses capacités balistiques et les
contraintes et le troisième point c'est
que l'iran est un facteur de
déstabilisation par justement ses alliés
ses proxy ou ces organisations infra
étatique
c'est à dire les ministres qu'elles
financent en irak comme en syrie par le
hezbollah qui est financée qui a
toujours cette alliance bifaces qui tout
à la fois partis politiques présents à
la chambre et ce faisant interlocuteur
politique est reconnue dans la vie
politique libanaise et dans le même
temps avec la main gauche si je puis
dire mouvement terroriste qui
déstabilisent profondément le pays et
donc il faut une clarification de ce
sujet qui ne peut passer que par ce
double mécanisme de la contrainte et du
dialogue
je continue à poursuivre cette ligne je
ne crois pas à la violence absolue qui
seul conduit à la guerre et au
changement de régime
parce que je pense que personne n'est
capable de conduire une telle offensive
je pense simplement qu'il faut apporter
de la contrainte très forte sur le
régime et les dirigeantes beaucoup plus
que sur le peuple et qu'il faut y
adjoindre une capacité de négociation
incluant tous ces dossiers
quant au liban je pense que plus qu'une
visite et libanais attendent un
gouvernement des réformes et de la
responsabilité
nous nous continuons à avancer sur
l'aide aux ong et aux populations parce
que c'est ce que nous devons au peuple
libanais qui est un peuple frère
c'est ce que nous faisons depuis le
premier jour et nous continuerons à
l'accroître et à mobiliser mais je
continue pour ma part à défendre la
feuille de route que nous avons
présentées en septembre dernier et à
mettre la pression maximale pour qu' un
gouvernement se forme avec des
personnalités qui peuvent qui pourront
porter ses réformes
nous restons investis mais je ne peux
pas me substituer à celles et ceux qui
tiennent le système avec toutes ces
malfaçons et ses déséquilibres
j'espère que l'esprit de responsabilité
qui fait défaut depuis plusieurs mois
aura un sursaut le peuple le méritent
au delà de ça nous travaillons aussi
techniquement avec plusieurs partenaires
de la communauté internationale pour que
à un moment donné les systèmes de
financement si le gouvernement continue
est plutôt l'absence de gouvernement et
aux partis politiques continuer dans les
responsabilités qu'on puisse réussir à
préserver un système sous contrainte
international qui permettrait à ce
moment là le financement des activités
essentielles et en soutien au peuple
libanais
oh
bonjour francis brochet pour les
quotidiens régionaux du groupe ebra le
président bailly donne l'ambition
d'organiser un sommet mondial des
démocraties
est ce que ça vous paraît une bonne idée
parce que vous soutenez l'initiative je
soutient par principe initiative parce
que je pense que c'est toujours bon
quand il ya des initiatives par principe
en ayant parfois eu moi même j'ai trouvé
c'est toujours plus agréable d'avoir des
gens qui vous disent qu'ils sont prêts à
être des partenaires donc la france est
un partenaire des états unis d'amérique
je pense que c'est un concept qui
méritent d'être clarifiés et auquel il
faut maintenant donner un contenu et je
pense que d'ailleurs nos discussions
dans le cadre du g7 et de l'otan le
permettront et je pense que sur le sujet
des démocraties
il faut veiller à deux choses d'abord il
ne faudrait pas donner le sentiment que
c'est un club pro fermé parce qu'il ya
un universalisme des valeurs
démocratiques qui est un vrai
universalisme et donc je pense qu'il ne
faut pas en défensif donné le sentiment
à d'autres pays qui pourraient
s'affranchir en quelque sorte de ces
valeurs là parce qu'ils sont pas dans le
club et c'est d'ailleurs ce que nous
avons porté c'est ce qui est au coeur de
la charte et du mandat des nations unies
la deuxième chose c'est que je pense
qu'il faut lui donner un contenu actif
nos démocraties sont elles mêmes très
fragilisé notre union européenne vie des
reculs démocrate
quand on regarde dans certains pays la
situation de la liberté académie de la
presse des juges et donc nous devons
être très cohérent et très exigeant
d'abord avec nous mêmes
je pense que une des batailles
l'essentiel c'est celle justement de la
restauration de nos libertés et des
devoirs qui l'accompagnent sur les
réseaux sociaux et dans l'espace
numérique
je pense que ça c'est essentiel quand on
a vu combien les réseaux sociaux et les
plateformes par leur usage prouvé
vaciller une démocratie compenser
robuste à tous en début d'année au
capitole quand on voit ce que les
réseaux sociaux peuvent conduire à faire
pour le terrorisme la haine en ligne le
retour de l'antisémitisme avec cette
forme violence le retour de toutes les
formes d'exclusion l'homophobie
transphobie tout ce qu'ils ont pour moi
c'est l'une des batailles les plus
essentiels donc c'est en tout cas si on
avance sur ce sujet je l'espère l'un des
points clés de ce sommet
le présidente tu montes sur le gardien
nous savons que les britanniques vont
réouvrir les négociations sur le
protocole des vignerons de nord et il ya
d'autres sujets de tension entre le
rugby et
la france est ce que vous aurez une
réunion bilatérale avec bob johnson et
si oui qu'est-ce que vous allez lui dire
écoute et nous aurons évidemment une
réunion bilatérale d'ores et déjà prévu
de la même manière que j'ai eu
l'opportunité d'échanger avec lui il y a
quelques jours nous parlons surtout de
l'agenda du g7 et de tous les sujets que
nous évoquons ensemble aujourd'hui je
pense que ça n'est pas sérieux de
vouloir revoir au mois de juillet ce
qu'on a finalisé après des années de
nuit de débat et de travail au mois de
décembre
je pense que c'est pas sérieux entre
nous c'est pas sérieux vis-à-vis de nos
peuples
c'est pas un sujet entre royaume uni et
la france c'est un sujet entre les
européens et le royaume uni nous avons
un protocole d'accord et de séparation
si je puis dire dans le cadre duquel il
ya ce protocole nord-irlandais et nous
avons un très petit commerce
il a été péniblement discuter pendant
des années et discuter à l'initiative je
le rappelle des britanniques pas des
européens qui ont décidé de sortir six 6
mois après on dit ce qu'on vous a
négocié on sait pas le respecter
alors ça veut dire que plus rien et
respectables se croire dans la force des
traités je crois dans l'esprit de
sérieux
rien n'est négociable tout est
applicable
bonsoir je vends brive l afp est ce que
votre décision sur park allait
directement lié à la crise politique au
mali est ce que ça veut dire que vous
n'avez pas été convaincus par
l'engagement du président par intérim
gorrite à de redonner le pouvoir aux
civils
l'an prochain ou est-ce que cette
décision est aussi lié à la popularité
grandissante de l'intervention en
afrique en france alors non je ne font
pas d'abord sur sur le deuxième le
deuxième élément votre question je ne
font pas des choix stratégiques ou
militaires sur les sondages et quels que
soient ces sondages ce n'est pas ça qui
guide mon choix même si je pense que
c'est toujours important de convaincre à
la fois nos concitoyens de ce que nous
conduisons à l'international et les
opinions publiques aussi des états où on
sonne du bien fondé de nos opérations
mais force est de constater qu'il ya
aussi un phénomène d'usure et que et un
sentiment généralisé coup perd le fil de
ce pourquoi nous sommes là moi je leur
dis avec force nos concitoyens comme à
toutes les opinions publiques africaines
la france n'est en afrique à la demande
des africains
la france n'est là que parce que des
états souverains nous ont demandé d'être
là pour ne pas s'effondrer eux-mêmes et
elle n'est là que pour lutter contre le
terrorisme mais la forme de notre
présence celle d'opérations extérieures
engageant plus de 5000 hommes maintenant
que plusieurs années n'est plus adapté à
la réalité des combats c'est ce que
j'avais dit à pau commençant à la une
infection
c'est ce que j'ai redit avec force
n'djamena où j'avais demandé comme vous
souvent dans souvenez peut-être un
sursaut un accroissement des forts du
retour de l'état dans ces régions je
suis obligé de constater que dans
plusieurs états de la région
il n'y a pas eu un réengagement des
décideurs pour faire revenir l'état et
l'administration dans les zones qu'on
libère du terrorisme militairement et en
responsabilité ce n'est pas le rôle de
la france de se substituer à perpétuité
aux états le terrorisme restera à l'état
endémique dans la région s'il n'y a pas
un retour des services publics des
projets aidés
timité pour les populations donc très
clairement en prenons nos
responsabilités transformant notre
opération pour être cohérent et ensuite
ça n'est pas lié aux évolutions récentes
au tchad
comme m c'est un mouvement profond et
une conviction c'est aussi la clarté et
la cohérence du discours que j'ai à
l'égard de l'afrique
nous sommes là en soutien des états pas
en substitution au service des
populations pas dans la compréhension
avec elle ensuite pour ce qui est du cas
du mali
je pense que la décision que la cdoa
prise de reconnaître un putschiste
militaire six mois après lui avoir
refusé ce droit créer une mauvaise
restent prudents pour les africains eux
mêmes
je vous le dis en toute franchise avec
beaucoup d'amitié pour les collègues
d'africable d'abord pour la cedeao elle
même suite par le précédent que cela
crée chez beaucoup de voisins
je pense que c'est une erreur c'est leur
décision je la respecte
pour ce qui nous concerne je lis
toujours dit nous nous demandons aux
nouvelles autorités maliennes qu'elle
respecte d'abord les échéances et que
ensuite elles tiennent leurs engagements
et des clarifications très clair c'est à
dire la place de tous les mouvements
politiques et partis politiques
un cadre politique inclusif le respect
des populations civiles
la mise en oeuvre des accords d'alger la
clarté dans les discussions avec les
groupes terroristes djihadistes qui sont
présents dans la région et donc pas de
dialogue et de compromis sions est
évidemment le respect des échéances qui
ont été validés dès le début par la
cedeao et le passage à des élections de
première qualification été apportée par
les nouvelles autorités maliennes
elles ont été confirmés dans le cadre de
la médiation menée par les pays de la
région et que la france soutient je
parle de la médiation donc les choses
vont dans le bon sens
néanmoins comme vous l'avez vu nous
avons décidé de suspendre les opérations
que nous menons
en partenariat avec les armées manière
et je dis ça avec un immense respect
pour les armées maliennes nos armées
sont désarmés soeur de l'ordre mais il
ya un cadre politique pour intérieure et
donc nous nous reprendrons les
opérations communes qu'une fois que
l'ensemble des engagements que je viens
d'évoquer seront de manière effective
mise en oeuvre par les nouvelles
autorités maliennes se souhaite compte
tenu de la menace que le terrorisme
représente dans la région qui se
conforme à nos engagements le plus vite
possible mais c'est notre responsabilité
on ne peut pas souffrir l'ambiguïté on
ne peut pas mener des opérations
conjointes avec des pouvoirs qui
décident de discuter avec des groupes
qui à côté de ça tire sur nos enfants
c'est ce qu'il faut vous représentiez je
ne sais pas expliquer aux parents d'un
soldat français que je renvoie ses
frères d'armes alors qu'il est tombés
sur le champ d'honneur aux côtés d'
armée qui décide de négocier avec leurs
enseignants cette ambiguïté elle existe
sur le terrain tant qu'elle n'est pas
complètement levé je ne peux pas
reprendre les opérations communes et je
ne le ferai pas je distingue bien la
transformation de barkan qui relève d'un
mouvement plus profond avec la
suspension de nos opérations conjointes
avec les autorités maliennes qui elle
relève d'un contexte spécifique et de
clarification que nous demandons à ces
dernières si elles sont apportées et
j'espère au plus vite à ce moment là
nous serons en mesure de reprendre les
coopérations avec les transformations
progressives que j'évoque le président
du marais france télévisions vous avez
dit vous annoncerez les modalités de ces
nouvelles opérations d'ici quelques
semaines
est-ce que vous pouvez néanmoins nous
donner des indications quelles
réductions d'effectifs et aqua sera
donné la priorité de ceux qui resteront
sur place parce que ce sera les forces
spéciales ou davantage des formateurs
pour
les armées des pays partenaires sur les
chiffres je sais que dans parce que nous
ferons un retrait de certaines emprises
qui sont celles d'opérations extérieures
devons le faire de manière organisée en
sécurisant nos forces armées et donc le
chef d'état-major des armées général
lecointre depuis d'ailleurs plus d'un an
travaille en toute confidentialité avec
l'ensemble des états majors proposer des
différents scénarios j'ai vu ces
derniers jours valider un scénario de
référence
nous allons continuer à l'affiner ça
passe par un dialogue avec nos
partenaires africains nos partenaires
européens et internationaux
d'évidence et ensuite nous ferons
évidemment des opérations à un rythme
qui sécurise pleinement nos soldats à
chaque étape
l'état final recherché c'est évidemment
de réduire nos emprises multiples de
réduire la logique opérations
extérieures de garder deux piliers un
pilier lutte contre le terrorisme avec
des forces spéciales structuré autour de
takouba avec évidemment là dessus une
forte composante française avec encore
plusieurs centaines de soldats et des
forces africaines européennes
internationales à nos côtés mais qui
aura vocation à faire des interventions
strictement lutte contre le terrorisme
et avec beaucoup moins d'emplois il y
adjoindre évidemment des capacités de
renseignement qui permettent ces
projections et la sécurisation de ces
dernières et puis il y aura un deuxième
pilier est un pilier coopération avec
les armées partenaires ou là évidemment
nous avons déjà des structures
existantes dans le cadre de barkan dans
le cadre de tutelle notre part mais nous
allons compléter je souhaite que nous
aussi un dialogue avec non seulement les
membres du g5 sahel mais les autres
armées de la région en particulier du
golfe de guinée pour renforcer notre
coopération dans ce cadre et avoir
vraiment un cadre de coopération
renforcée et puis je n'oublie pas la
minus mas qui en termes de sécurisation
de la région et de présence sur le
terrain jouent un rôle très importante
avec le mandat qui est le sien et qui
est extrêmement importante dans l'idée
de mayenne
moi je me suis président sarah qui
quitta pour un coach hadj après que ça
paiera ça chez vous des affections
génétiques et ce goût la chine cette
année où 17 des pays
un drastique sont invités comme et
l'australie est-ce que vis-à-vis de la
chine
la france va s'aligner sur la position
des états unis en matière de sécurité
et concrètement est ce que la france va
participer aux cadres eux s'appelle le
quad le cadre des quatre pays diallo et
des vignerons sur le plan économique
quelle est votre position sur la
nouvelle route de la soie placer sur
l'a2 pacifique
l'occasion de présenter dès le printemps
2010 8 notre stratégie avec nos
partenaires de référence l'inde
l'australie
plusieurs autres partenaires de la
région avec lequel nous sommes en train
d'avancer évidemment que japon le coeur
de notre stratégie indo pacifique c'est
d'abord celle d'un pays qui est membre
de cette région
je le dis parce que la france est une
puissance indo pacifique
nous avons plus d'un million de nos
compatriotes qui vivent dans cet espace
nous avons des forces armées qui sont
présentes dans cet espace polynésie en
nouvelle calédonie à la réunion et
mayotte est évidemment une présence
maritime avec de nombreuses opérations
conjointes qui historiquement sont
toujours déployées se sont multipliés
ces dernières années notre approche en
termes de stratégie indo pacifique n'est
en aucun cas un alignement sur qui que
ce soit et la ligne que je plaide pour
la france je l'espère pour l'europe et
tous nos alliés n'est ni d'être
vassaliser par la chine ni d'être aligné
sur ce sujet avec les états unis
d'amérique mais de défendre avec nos
partenaires régionaux
cette ligne de respect des équilibres et
pour reprendre la formule de mon ami
l'ancien président ancien premier
ministre australien
d'ailleurs dans un esprit de continuité
de premier ministre scott morrison qui
sera ici même dans quelques semaines
défend aussi cette ligne celle de la
liberté de la souveraineté
ce que nous voulons assurer dans la
région c'est quand quelque sorte l'inde
au pacifique ne soient pas écrasés dans
une confrontation sino-américaines et
que l'un d'eux pacifique ne soit pas non
plus une zone en quelque sorte satellite
de la chine
nous sommes attachés à ce que les
grandes puissances amies puisse dans la
région d'abord défendre nos valeurs
démocratiques pluralistes de respect des
équilibres qu'ensuite indo pacifique
soit aussi une zone de souveraineté
technologique et de financement ceci
suppose des partenariats multiples qui
impose de respecter tous les partenaires
la chine qui est un partenaire
économique essentiel pour tous les pays
de la région tels que nous avons
d'ailleurs souvent avec leur ministre
aux néo zélandaise aussi s'est associé
stratégie en la matière mais les états
unis d'amérique sont un partenaire
commercial technologique important voilà
l'esprit dans lequel nous poursuivons
cette stratégie indo pacifique de
manière très claire je ne veux pas de
conflictuelles et inutile mais nous
voulons poursuivre cette ligne un peu
indépendante
cette troisième voie qui je pense est la
bonne pour les états de la région pour
ce qui est des nouvelles routes de la
soie
je pense que c'est un concept
géopolitique fort porté par la chine
notre souhait c'est qu'elles puissent
pleinement s'intégrer dans le cadre du
multilatéralisme que nous défendons
qu'elles puissent s'intégrer dans les
objectifs climatiques que j'évoquais que
cette route de la soie soit verte et
qu'elles permettent de financer des
infrastructures d'énergie dans tous les
pays la route de la soie qui
correspondent aux objectifs des accords
de paillis de paris qu'elle 5 lui est
sincère dans les objectifs de l' ocde
et du g20 en particulier dans le cadre
de la soutenabilité des dettes des pays
récipiendaires africains m'ont africains
et donc qu'elles soient en fait une
route de partenariat avec les autres
puissances d'asie du sud-est asie
mineure proches moyen-orient afrique et
europe apaisé et respectueux du cadre
international
mais pour moi ça doit être une
initiative qui s'inscrit dans le respect
du multilatéralisme et de ce cadre
international et de l'universalisme de
nos valeurs président loïc senior pour
un ses news je reviens sur ce que vous
avez appelé un dossier clé de ce geste
est là la haine en ligne et comment
lutter contre cette haine vous en avait
parlé avec des termes qui ont parfois
ces polémiques ans sauvagement des
esprits vous avez dit comment aller plus
loin quand on voit qu'ici en france une
jeune fille mila pour ne pas la citer
est harcelé en ligne depuis plus d'un an
maintenant et ça continue malgré des
condamnations judiciaires et
parallèlement est-ce qu'on pressent le
bon curseur en s'arrêtant aux réseaux
sociaux
quand on voit parfois cette violence et
cette haine dépasse vous l'avez voulu
expérimenter cette semaine les
frontières de la haine en ligne et se
retrouve sur le terrain réellement je ne
mettrai pas tous les sujets sur le même
plan et je pense qu'il faut garder
beaucoup de clarté et les d'esprit de
distinction en la matière donc je vais
juste m'attacher à parler de de lijn je
pense que toutes les sociétés
démocratiques sont en train de devenir
de plus en plus violente
nous voyons du capitole aux états unis
d'amérique à la violence de
manifestations devant le bundestag ont
ans était absolument inenvisageable à ce
que nous avons nous même vécu lors de
crises sociales importantes il ya deux
ans
ou encore aujourd'hui au quotidien je
pense que c'est évidemment il ya une
réponse immédiate à laquelle nous avons
elle est sécuritaire et judiciaire
enfin devons tous comme un maître
prendre deux pas de recul et regardez ce
phénomène est quelque chose qui se passe
de plus grave est plus profond qu'elle
ne répond pas simplement avec plus de
moyens et plus de durcissement quelque
chose se passe qui fait que un processus
de civilisation qui était à l'heure et
qui avait dans les sociétés
démocratiques réduit la violence revient
moi je crois qu'il y a à la fois une
crise des économies marché une crise de
la démocratie une crise d économie de
marché
parce que l' équilibre qui était le
nôtre qui était que au fond croyez dans
des économies ouvertes dans le fait que
ont commercé librement supposait que il
y ait une perspective de progrès pour
tout le monde ceci est rompu depuis
plusieurs décennies et donc créer du
désespoir social qui justifie même si
c'est injustifiable toutes les formes de
violence et donc nous devons transformer
en profondeur le capitalisme et
l'économie de marché international pour
le rendre plus juste
et pour calmer la racine de la colère
qui est ce sentiment d'injustice qui lie
à notre société
ça c'est une réalité profonde on ne peut
pas le faire dans un seul pays pour ça
que j'ai toujours défendu cet agenda sur
le plan international la france étant
l'un des pays qui corrige le plus par
son système fiscal ces inégalités
mais il doit faire beaucoup plus pour
prévenir ces inégalités par l'éducation
la formation la création d'opportunités
et la réindustrialisation est pour moi
le premier élément pour répondre à cela
c'est vraiment un cadre international
qui corrige les inégalités de notre
économie de marche et quand on fait ce
qu'on est en train de se dire sur la
taxation
quand on a un cadre plus inclusive quand
on crée de nouvelles normes économiques
sociales et environnementales en oeuvre
cette direction quand on bâtit un agenda
régional
de relocalisation de réindustrialisation
on corrige une aberration des années 80
et 90 qui a voulu en quelque sorte que
nos sociétés démocratiques par le
commerce international ont réussi à
sortir de la pauvreté
des centaines de millions de femmes et
d'hommes de la grande pauvreté donc un
autre bout du monde mais en plongée dans
la précarité beaucoup de leurs
concitoyens on va donc réindustrialiser
nos collègues qui le deuxième grand
levier c'est la nuit entre les narines
parce que la crise de nos démocraties
est une crise de valeurs de principes
parce que nous avons abandonné les
règles de base de l'ordre public
quand il s'agit de l'internet mais par
un processus subreptice et je dis ça
nous avons tous vécu internet a été créé
pour partager l'intelligence et le
savoir académique historiquement ensuite
on a un partager l'information l'analyse
est formidable c'est une expérience
unique au monde on peut partager dans le
monde entier en temps réel ce que nous
vivons simplement cette mondialisation
instantanée de l'intelligence et de la
communication s'est transformée peut
être était ce prévisible en
mondialisation instantanée des émotions
et les émotions sont avant tout les
patients et donc ce que nous avions
patiemment construit à travers les âges
pour être un grand pays des lumières une
société démocratique se déconstruit à
vue d'oeil dans ce nouvel espace
on y réfléchit plus on y partage des
chocs des images des phrases
décontextualisés des passions dans les
passions c'est toujours la passion la
plus extrême qui triomphe
la passion raisonnable et émollientes on
cherche tous l'amour absolu pas l'amour
moyens et c'est vrai de toutes les
passions et donc c'est en train de
devenir l'espace du
et la philosophie de cet espace c'était
la liberté non régulés parce qu'il était
nu d'ailleurs par des associations au
début par des acteurs qui ne cherchaient
pas le profil je vous le rappelle il a
été ensuite développé par des acteurs
privés et ont réussi à faire beaucoup de
profits et donc nous sommes à un moment
de notre histoire où nous devons réguler
cet espace on doit le réguler quand il
fait des surprofits en le taxant c'est
ce qu'on est en train de faire mais on
doit réguler dans son cadre avec une
idée simple nous sommes ici dans cette
salle avec des règles que nous avons
appris que nos familles nous ont
apprises puis notre école et la vie en
société
celle du respect et d'un ordre public
qu'est que la liberté que nous avons les
uns des autres ne vaut que parce qu'on a
des devoirs et que cette liberté a des
limites
aucune de mes libertés comme de vos
libertés ne sont absolus en ligne cela
ne vaut plus la vie en ligne
c'est d'avoir une cagoule et d'insultés
et de menaces est pour beaucoup de gens
et bien quand vous habituer des
concitoyens du monde partout à ce que
leur quotidien
tard le soir tôt le matin dans la
journée six mille sont oisifs un exister
que par les insultes qu'il profère
l'entousiasme que la sucent que cela
suscite les groupes d'admirateurs que
cela génère encagoulées derrière un
pseudonyme
chez nous où l'anonymat ne vaut par
protection de votre liberté nous sommes
des états de démocratie où vous pouvez
avoir une liberté d'expression alors je
crois pouvoir dire que l'utilisation de
ces réseaux est l'exact contraire de ce
que ceux qui les ont créés voulait et
elle menace par leur fonctionnement
notre vie démocratique donc il faut pas
s'étonner que des gens lorsqu'ils sont
dans la rue
se met à avoir le même comportement
qu'ils ont des heures durant
parce qu'ils sont derrière leur écran
sur l'europe téléphone nous sommes en
train de rebâtir le pays riches je le
constate comme vous je pense qu'il n'est
pas une fatalité mais il nous faut
réagir vite et donc rebâtir ce que nous
avons su bâtir ce que j'appelle cet
ordre public des règles des interdits
qui n'entrave pas une expression de ses
libertés qui permettent de les conjuguer
entre elles et des valeurs de respect
simplement comme cet espace est mondiale
et la bible nous ne pouvons le faire que
si nous engageons toutes les puissances
de la planète et tous les acteurs de
l'internet
c'est exactement ce que nous avons
commencé avec l'appel de christchurch et
ce que nous devons continuer et
accélérer et je le dis parce que sinon
de toute façon il y aura des régulations
de cette parole mais ce ne seront pas
des gouvernements démocratiquement élus
qu'ils seront pas ce que j'espère que
les prochains débats démocratiques terme
et rondes permettront d'ailleurs de
décider d des contraintes et des
libertés qu'on met sur ces personnes et
ces réseaux sociaux aujourd'hui nous
n'avons pas ce débat nous n'en n'avons
pas le pouvoir mais aujourd'hui les
plateformes ont le pouvoir qui peuvent
décider de vous éradiquer de vos comptes
ça n'est pas démocratique non plus donc
il est urgent que nous créions un ordre
public et un droit international public
et privé décidée par des gouvernements
démocratiquement élus de ce que sont les
droits les devoirs et les règles sur cet
espace parce que il en va de notre vidéo
c'est encore un petit quart d'heure
e bonjour jean michel lahmi nouvel
économiste
vous venez de parler de souveraineté
européenne militaire alors qu'elles vont
le peut jouer la force de dissuasion
dans ce cadre au plan bilatéral nous
avons nous avions j'allais répondre des
accords de lancaster avec ton royaume
uni que vont-ils devenir
et puis ou plan européen est-ce que
quelle est la doctrine d'emploi de la
force de dissuasion les intérêts vitaux
de la france sont ils des intérêts
vitaux de 26 sur ce sujet je ne
réduirait pas la souveraineté militaire
à la composante nucléaire et la
dissuasion pour moi une autonomie
stratégique c'est déjà avoir en europe
des capacités industrielles communes la
possibilité de simplifier nos modèles
d'avoir une industrie européenne et donc
des armements pour l'ensemble de nos
armées qui ne dépendent pas d'une
puissance extérieure dans leur
utilisation et les limites que nous
aurons défini ci
deuxième chose c'est d'avoir
suffisamment de pays européens qui est
un qui ont un modèle complet d'armé
comme nous l'avons d'ailleurs en france
c'est le choix d'investissement que nous
avons fait à travers la programmation
militaire
dans ce cadre-là la dissuasion nucléaire
est une composante essentielle pour la
france sur ce qui est deux
notre doctrine de dissuasion je vous
renvoie au discours que j'ai tenu à
l'école de guerre il ya plusieurs mois
qui continue à prévaloir ses vues des
termes précis il n'y a pas en changer
une virgule et pour être très explicite
avec vous c'est évidemment l'un des
apports de la france à la crédibilité de
l'europe et pour ce qui est du lien avec
nos amis britanniques traité de
lancaster continue de prévaloir même
après
bonjour monsieur le président jean marie
bodo pour europe 1 un mot sur les
vaccins coville quand de nombreux pays
appelle notamment les états unis à la
levée des brevets vous proposer je cite
la dérogations limitées dans le temps et
l'espace de la propriété intellectuelle
vous préciser le temps du pic de
l'épidémie vous en avait déjà parlé en
fait en afrique ya deux semaines et en
même temps vous dit souvent qu'il faut
de nombreuses années pour qu'une
production qui se met en place au panier
de 3 à 4 ans à pretoria est ce que cette
annonce de dérogation n'est pas
finalement un peu un trompe l'oeil pour
uniquement se placer face aux annonces
américaines
une annonce purement symbolique car en
fait inapplicable d'un point de vue
industriel on a peine à imaginer qu'il y
aura des production de vaccins sans
brevet avant la fin du pic de l'épidémie
merci mais donc quelle crédibilité de
donner des coups à lanus américaine en
me disant ça de fait elle se place de
manière hilarante
si vous remplacez manière vous vous le
placez de manière je cite le temps du
pic de l'épidémie diane kouame mais
alors premièrement j'attends d'avoir la
proposition précise américaine c'est
très important je pense que jamais les
états unis d'amérique nous proposerons
de lever de manière perpétuelle de
propriété intellectuelle aucun état
aucune puissance économique qui a des
capacités d'innovation ne dira chez moi
il n'ya plus de rémunération de la
propriété intellectuelle est ce que ça
veut dire qu'à la seconde d'après lui
personne ni 9 févr je pensais ce qu'il
faut comprendre quelle est la clé
derrière tout ça c'est qu'il nous faut
articuler la capacité la solidarité la
capacité à produire sans que la
propriété intellectuelle sont un frein
et en même temps la juste rémunération
de la propriété intellectuelle pour les
gens qui innove c'est une course de
vitesse et donc les gens qui innovent
veulent pouvoir être récompensés donc
aucune économie du monde ne dira je
renonce à la propriété intellectuelle je
suis pour un modèle mais il n'ya plus de
propriété intellectuelle je pense qu'il
faut être là dessus très clair non
premièrement ce que je dis si on veut
être crédible à court terme
la levée des brevets n'était pas n'est
pas la réponse la plus immédiate
qu'elles viennent des états unis qu'elle
soit portée par nous-mêmes ou d'autres
c'est pas vrai
la première réponse est là elle est dans
la main des américains et j'espère que
ce sera une avancée du g7
parce que là c'est un blocage américain
c'est la levée des restrictions à
l'export ceux qui pendant des mois à
empêcher le sérum institute of india de
produire pour lui-même et pour l'afrique
ce sont les restrictions à l'export mise
par plusieurs économies dont l'économie
américaine premier point donc je pense
que ne faut pas qu'on regarde aussi des
choses à l'envers
première étape c'est celle là parce que
l'on parle des vaccins de maintenant
deuxième chose c'est les dons de vaccins
je pense que c'est une annonce massive
que les états unis s'engagent dans le
don de doses ils vont en préciser le
calendrier
je pense très vite mais je m'en félicite
je pense que c'est bien ce formidable et
ça ça va nous et on doit être s'ils sont
plus ambitieux que nous on doit
rejoindre leurs ambitions et faire au
moins autant
donc ça c'est formidable sur la
propriété intellectuelle ils ont posé le
principe
pour l'instant je n'ai pas vu de détails
d'une proposition américaine nous nous
avons au début dit en europe et 1 à
porto
vous étiez là je m'en souviens nadi
d'abord travaillons à ce qu'on appelle
l'aménagement des accords trices qui
sont d accord de propriété
intellectuelle qui ont été négociées au
moment de la gestion des trithérapies où
on a permis par justement le mécanisme
de licence obligatoire d'avoir la
possibilité pour des preuves pour les
pays certains produits de produire des
trithérapies à très bas coût sans que la
propriété intellectuelle soit une
contrainte
c'était pas une suppression de cette
propriété mais c'est ce qu'on appelait
les licences obligatoires
nous on a répondu à 110 ans on a un
cadre essayons de regarder
il est géré par ce qu'on appelle le
medicines patent pool c'était d'ailleurs
le fruit à l'époque d'une bataille menée
par les sud-africains et nelson mandela
il semble que ce cadre m d'abord
beaucoup de temps à se mettre en oeuvre
j'ai étudié après j'ai regardé parce que
j'étais impatient je voulais qu'on
essaie de tenir les choses très vite et
j'ai vu que ça allait prendre du temps
plusieurs mois certainement et plusieurs
années et l'âge ou rejoindre ça peut pas
suffire
deuxièmement certains m'ont dit quand il
ya des licences obligatoires il ya des
mécanismes de rétorsion à l'égard des
états
les utilisent et donc ça reste un
mécanisme bise
du coup ce que je vous ai dit c'est
exactement la proposition qui est faite
par l'afrique du sud et man et donc nous
nous avons travaillé sur cette base là
c'est le président ramaphosa qui a dit
par lucidité parce qu'il sait que c'est
déjà très fort levon le pour certains
pays et pendant l'épidémie
mais c'est déjà énorme j'espère qu'on
aura l'accord là dessus j'espère mais
j'espère je vais regarder ce que là ce
qui est la proposition américaine
elle n'est pas mieux disantes elle est
moins précise mais si elle propose
quelque chose de plus efficace que ce
qu'on a franchement je la regardais en
quelques heures et je suis prêt à me
ranger
je pense que le principe qui régira la
position de la france sur ce sujet c'est
que jamais la propriété intellectuelle
ne doit être un frein à la production la
plus rapide possible de vaccins sur le
sol africain ou indo pacifique président
à la fois a eu cette idée de dire on
l'aise pendant un temps donné
et de toute façon vous le livre est
toujours dans des géographies de mais
pourquoi parce que sinon c'est un
mécanisme de coups de contournement et
puis un laboratoire qui produira
essaiera d'aller produire dans un pays
où il ya peu la propriété intellectuelle
et vous ne paierez plus rien aux
laboratoires qui est mauvais donc le
cadre que je vous ai donné il est juste
plus précis parce qu'on l'a écrite ont
proposé je crois que les américains dans
les prochaines heures vont arriver avec
une proposition écrite et on va regarder
ce qui est plus efficace et de plus
ambitieux et moi je n'en serai appelé
sur la plus ambitieuse
ce que j'ai défendue c'est la position
sud africaine à laquelle nous sommes
arrangés
monsieur le président bonjour allison
tassin pour tf1 est elle si les
conditions sanitaires qui entoure le g7
dont il est question sont très
restrictives alors se pose la question à
quel horizon peut-on envisager la mise
en place d'un pass sanitaire de façon
peut-être un peu plus homogène et en
particulier avec des partenaires hors
union européenne peut être aussi les
américains et que sur un plan plus
nationale des assouplissements sont ils
à attendre par exemple sur le port du
masque en extérieur sur quels critères
les préfets peuvent ils intervenir est
ce qu'une levée généralisé est envisagé
de votre côté et puis enfin de questions
d'actualité l'homme qui vous a agressé
mardi a été condamné à 18 mois de prison
dont quatre fermes ou satisfait vous de
cette décision de justice rapide
oui pendant plusieurs heures
merci jean christophe ploquin de la
croix monsieur le président j'ai une
question très rapide sur le mali est ce
que vous avez sollicité vous avez
mentionné les états unis ce que vous
avez sollicité une aide renforcée des
états unis dans cette région c'est
qu'elle est surtout
ces dernières années elle est en matière
de renseignement transport est ce que
vous avez demandé les forces spéciales
américaines sur le terrain une question
plus sûre sur le fmi et le désarmement
comment est-ce que la france où les
européens peuvent mettre un pied dans la
porte
entre les états unis et la russie est ce
que la france peut le faire avec la
grande bretagne en tant que pays dotés
vous avez mentionné ça dans lequel cadre
est ce que ce serait ce que c'est dans
le temps parce que c'est dans l'union
européenne
est ce qu'il ya vraiment une façon de
peser sur ces négociations pour les
européens frédéric haziza rajhi monsieur
le président vous allez rencontrer les
principaux dirigeants de la planète à
l'occasion des sommets du g7 de l'otan à
la peau plus tard du g20 là je voudrais
rebondir sur votre réponse à une
question précédente est ce que vous
considérez que vos homologues sont
vraiment confrontés à la même situation
que vous ici en france c'est à dire et
cette violence ambiante mais aussi à la
montée des populismes encore à cette
remise en cause de l'autorité et de
l'ordre public au delà
qu'est ce que la gifle de tain
l'hermitage dit de l'état de la société
française de la vie politique et du
débat public
les sens et les présidentielles en
turquie et oui ça fait déjà grincer
investir 15 morin et vous avez dit que
vous allez rencontrer avec monsieur
erdogan et qui a demandé de se
rencontrer en rencontres bilatérales
est-ce que vous pouvez nous dire un peu
plus de détails parce que vous avez dit
que vous allez clarifier vous pourriez
clarifier un petit peu avec nous aussi
quel sujet délicat le sujet vous allez
avoir des quels sont les sujets merci
le président henri menace de politique
on vous l'avez dit vous-même la
crédibilité la pandémie à tester la
crédibilité du g7
vous n'avez même pas pu vous réunir au
pire moment de la pandémie à cause du
président 30
entre temps certains dans le club ont
pratiqué le nationalisme vaccinale etc
ou est-ce que le monde devrait vous
écouter aujourd'hui sur la pandémie
en tant que club et y at il des mesures
à prendre dans le club du g7 pour le
protéger d'une paralysie possible en cas
d'un autre trempe
merci bien
je vais répondre à ces cinq dernières
questions sur les conditions sanitaires
notre objectif comme vous savez que nous
avons d'ores et déjà un mécanisme de
passes sanitaires les règles en ont été
décrites par les membres du gouvernement
l'objectif est qu'ils puissent être en
application complète partir du 1er
juillet on va essayer de le mettre en
place d'ailleurs un peu plus tôt si on
peut avec quelques états voisins pour le
tester puis on utilise aussi ce même
mécanisme comme vous le savez pour des
événements autorisant des débordements
de jauge
je crois que l'objectif c'est qu'à
partir du 1er juillet il soit opérant
entre états européens et avec nos
principaux partenaires qu'on ait des
protocoles convergent ce sont des
décisions qui relève de chaque état
membre
mais c'est un cadre de coordination qui
permettra d'harmoniser nos réponses
et donc c'est ce qui va nous permettre
durant cet été d'organiser les mobilités
en particulier de pouvoir aussi recevoir
des touristes qui viendront par exemple
des états unis d'amérique et qui
pourront s'ils sont testés dans les
dernières heures du mans vaccinés avec
le certificat no montrant rejoindre le
territoire
pour ce qui est des allègements il ya
toujours eu des possibilités sont en
particulier sur la question du masque
d'aménagement locaux qui étaient à la
main des prêts faits elle demeure après
moi je pense qu'il faut qu'on applique
avec méthode
le protocole
sûr que nous nous sommes donné et je
pense que il y avait il ya un mois
beaucoup de scepticisme l'entendiez me
disais je l'avais mis en place une
ouverture progressive
regardez combien de cas vous avez vous
auriez dû mettre beaucoup plus de
contraintes sanitaires vous n'avez pas y
arriver je constate que on a plutôt bien
organisé
ces phases successives et que les
françaises et les français l'ont compris
ils ont adhéré et savent que il ne faut
ni contraintes inutiles ni précipitation
qui mettrait en péril ce que nous avons
durement tai chi donc je pense que
s'ouvre depuis hier une phase de trois
semaines qui nous permet de retrouver
certains plaisirs la pratique du sport
amateur des salles de sport les des
restaurants des jauges un peu
supplémentaires le coût trop le
couvre-feu à 23h et en effet des des
contraintes gardons les trois semaines
parce que c'est ce qui va nous permettre
de surveiller les choses et de voir que
ça ne dégrade pas l'épidémie et surtout
ça va nous permettre de continuer à
vacciner massivement chaque vaccin
gagner et quelqu'un qu'on protège contre
l'épidémie qui évite sa rediffusion à
partir du 30 juin s'ouvrira une nouvelle
phase qui nous permet d'envisager
peut-être d'autres ouvertures et à ce
moment-là manière plus généralisée des
changements je suis encore très prudents
moi je demande à voir
donc voilà il ya une stratégie elle a
été présentée jeu plutôt me tenir à ce
qu'elle réussit pour le moment donc je
n'étais pas pour la lenteur je ne suis
pas pour la précipitation à tomber au
bon rythme et je remercie encore une
fois les françaises et les français des
efforts qui sont les leurs sur ensuite
bon cet épisode
sur lesquels vous êtes revenu ainsi que
vous mais monsieur aziz a gelé dit à
plusieurs reprises je pense qu' il ne
faut rien accepter des débordements à
l'égard de cette étude qui représente
une autorité publique
mais je ne veux pas en quelque sorte
exagérer la portée de cet acte je
m'explique rien accepter c'est à dire ne
rien banaliser la violence à l'égard de
celles et ceux qui sont dépositaires
d'une autorité publique soit parce
qu'ils sont fonctionnaires et élus de la
république est inacceptable et rythme
acceptable pour les raisons que
j'évoquais tout à l'heure
parce que dans une démocratie comme la
nôtre vous avez la liberté d'expression
vous pouvez me poser vous toutes et tous
ici aujourd'hui les questions vous
voulez il ya beaucoup de pays où c'est
pas possible il ya des pays même en
europe c'est plus en plus difficile ça
l'est en france et que ceux qui portent
des discours extrêmes y compris d'un
champ politique
voilà responsabilité aussi qu'ils ont
quand dans cette direction à faire
croire aux gens que ce ne serait pas
possible
la liberté d'expression est là elle est
dans la rue la liberté de manifestation
et là la liberté politique et dans notre
pays pour se présenter aux élections
j'allais dire j'en suis l'exemple vivant
vivant je ne venais pas d'une formation
politique existante
je n'avais pas de moyens mirobolants je
n'étais pas installé dans le paysage
j'ai pu porter des idées les défendre
parce que les françaises et les français
me fait confiance et vous pouvez à dates
régulières nous pouvons à dates
régulières changer nos gouvernants et
nos législateurs démocratie cela suppose
le respect et la fin de la haine la
haine
elle se justifie dans les pays la
violence et de gouvernement
la haine la violence civile se justifie
existe à l'égard des dirigeants
quand on ne peut pas les changer ou ou
infléchir leur décision ce n'est pas le
cas de la france et donc toutes celles
et ceux qui évidemment participe de ses
gestes et toutes celles et ceux qu'il
est légitime de quelques manières met en
cause les fondamentaux même de notre
démocratie c'est à dire la possibilité
du dialogue de la conversation même de
la controverse démocratique qui est un
trésor
ces pouvoirs ne pas être d'accord
parfois nous échauffer les esprits
peut-être nous énerver autour d'une
table mais en commençant en s'immisçant
la discussion avec kamerhe ce2 et en ne
manquant jamais de considération pour la
personne humaine et sa dignité qu'il ya
en face demandes citoyennes citoyens et
donc rien rien rien rien dans notre pays
ne justifie quelques caravanes et en me
disant ce qui m'importe beaucoup plus
c'est toutes les menaces faites jour que
nos parlementaires nos mères peuvent
avoir et les violences nous sommes
ensuite sur la violence par elle-même
dans la société j'en ai beaucoup parlé
c'est là où je relève je viserai ce qui
s'est passé la violence c'est ce que
subissent les femmes qui meurent sous
les coups de leur compagnon leur
conjoint
la violence c'est ce que subissent trop
de nos concitoyens quand ils rentrent
chez eux qui sont dans les transports ça
c'est la violence la vraie est donc là
il faut une réponse implacable rapide je
me félicite d'une réponse rapide
je veux qu'on mette tout en oeuvre tous
les moyens ça fera partie des états
généraux de la justice pour que la
réponse soit à chaque fois la plus
rapide possible parce que c'est comme ça
qu'on redonne du sens au travail de nos
forces de l'ordre qu'on redonne du sens
à la victime qu'on redonne du sens aussi
à celui ou celle qui a commis le grave
ou le pire parce qu'il comprend ce qu'il
a en face de nous et donc ça c'est un
travail qui est le nôtre sur lequel le
gouvernement est à la tâche et sur
lequel nous allons continuer de vrai
c'est ça après je ne pense pas
qu'aujourd'hui la société française soit
dans un moment de grande tension
je pense qu'il y a
beaucoup de nos concitoyens qui sont
fatigués par l'épidémie qu'il y a chez
certains de nos concitoyens de la peur
du doute de l'anxiété les conséquences
de la solitude nous avons vécu des
grandes phases de tension sociale
il serait faux de dire que c'est le cas
aujourd'hui celles et ceux qui
m'accompagnent dans les déplacements aux
autres ce n'est pas vrai face à ce qu'on
ressent dès aujourd'hui il y à des
personnes qui ont plus souffert que
d'autres de l'épidémie et du confinement
parce qu'ils ont perdu des proches
qu'ils n'ont pas pu accompagner parce
qu'ils ont eux mêmes été frappés par
l'épidémie
parce que la solitude a été dure pour
elle sur le plan personnel parce qu'ils
avaient des difficultés avant parce
qu'ils ont eu à vivre de l' isolement
forcé et contraint parce qu'ils ont des
enfants des inquiétudes économiques et
sociales tout cela c'est ce qu'il nous
faudra prendre en compte dans la sortie
de crise et ce à quoi je vais m'employer
dans les prochaines semaines c'est ce
pourquoi je veux prendre le pouls du
pays mais ayant commencé à le faire je
ne vous dirai pas qu'il gagne ou je me
sens une violence sociale généralisée ce
n'est pas vrai mais il ya des individus
qui sont violents pour les raisons que
j'évoquais tout à l'heure et tassili à
tout
tous ces phénomènes qui sont à prendre
en compte je pense aussi que le peuple
français dans le moment que nous vivons
a le droit à une part d'insouciance et
d'optimisme
et donc je suis très préoccupé par tout
ce que nous vivons comme vous enfin nous
avons fait tellement d'efforts les
françaises et les français ont fait
tellement d'efforts ont eu tellement de
privations qui a envie de dire
collectivement
laissons-leur vivre ce moment une
écrasante majorité des français ne sont
pas des énervés ou des violents ce sont
des femmes et des hommes qui veulent
retrouver les plaisirs simples de la vie
l'art de vivre à la française
le plaisir de retrouver leurs proches la
possibilité de retravailler pleinement
de reconstruire leurs vies
professionnelle et familiale et donc je
pense que le temps il est de retour à la
vie il était un optimisme lucide et il
est au travail engagement dans le
travail
avant toute chose les autres problèmes
sont importants mais j'essaie de les
hiérarchiser
sinon on perd de vue je ne commenterai
par ailleurs évidemment pas de décider
particulière pour ce qui est du mali les
etats unis d'amérique sont depuis le
début un partenaire important pour nous
sur les 200 que vous avez voté transport
et renseignements notre demande
c'était de maintenir cet effort dont il
était menacé cela fut fait et je les en
remercie profondément notre souhait
c'est qu'il soit maintenu voire
renforcée si cela est possible et nous
avons formulé la demande ensuite dans le
cadre de la task force takouba nous
inviterons tous nos partenaires à se
joindre
et donc si les états unis d'amérique
sont prêts à mettre des forces spéciales
elles sont les bienvenus et je m'en
féliciterais pour ce qui est du poste
effet ni et de la maîtrise des armements
dans l'espace européen
nous devons être des interlocuteurs des
décideurs et des cosignataires et donc
nous allons en parler d'abord entre
alliés européens
ensuite entre alliés dans le cadre de
l'otan et ensuite nous devrons en parler
avec nos voisins et en particulier les
russes c'est ce cadre de coordination de
responsabilité responsabilités mais pour
ma part je considère que nous devons en
être les acteurs pour ce qui est de la
rencontre avec le président r de gamme
nous l'avons souhaité l'un et l'autre je
pense que c'est une bonne chose nous
avons besoin de me voir et d'échangés
nous avons des désaccords profonds et
nos savons nous avons menées parfois des
controverses et nous les assumons mais
je considère que quels que soient les
désaccords on doit toujours se parler et
donc je souhaite avec le président
erdogan
évidemment parler de l'otan et des
règles de conduite entre états alliés
je souhaite parler de la situation en
syrie de la situation en libye
de la situation au karabagh et conflit
entre l'arménie et l'azerbaïdjan
je souhaite parler également expliquer
le travail que la france conduit pour
lutter contre justement l'islamisme
radical que contre les séparatismes mais
qui n'est en aucune façon une aux
démarches de défiance à l'égard du culte
musulman au contraire je viens
d'expliquer à nouveau le cadre est
expliquée à la fois les règles que cela
pose et puis voir les coopérations que
nous pouvons envisager donc c'est une
discussion d'ensemble que je souhaite
avoir avec lui sur tous ces sujets et de
voir ce sur quoi on peut ré engagé un
travail exigeant ce sur quoi les
désaccords sont assumés pour ma part
vous savez j'ai toujours été clair
j'ai toujours été clair dans le dialogue
bilatérales y compris sur les sujets de
droits de l'homme de protection des
journalistes que vous êtes qui sont
emprisonnés d'universitaires ou
d'opposants politiques d'intellectuels
et d'artistes gelée était en tête à tête
ce qui m'a permis d'être en public et
donc j'ai besoin de ce discours en tête
à tête assumer je pense qu'il faut se
parler il continué ils continuent à se
parler même avec des désaccords ensuite
votre question est très juste je pense
malgré tout que le g7 a une crédibilité
parce qu il a continué à avancer et que
nous avons porté en particulier les
états du g7 membres du g20 ont porté
acta qui a été pour moi le pilier de
notre crédibilité dans la gestion de
l'épidémie
mais malgré toutes les vicissitudes et
c'est vrai pour certains le retour au
nationalisme
d'abord je veux dire les européens ont
été cohérents nous européens n'avons
jamais été dans l'unilatéralisme où le
nationalisme jamais
parfois d'ailleurs nos concitoyens nos
opinions publiques ont pu lui reprocher
si nous avons vacciné plus lentement que
d'autres c'est parce que dès le début de
la crise au moment où nous produisions
deux vaccins sur notre sol européen nous
en produisions un pour nous mêmes et un
qui partait à l'étranger
aucun autre pays
aucun autre espace au monde n'a eu cette
politique je l'assumé il faut le redire
sans rené pas maintenant
on n'existait pas pourquoi d'autres ont
vacciné plus vite que nous qui ont non
seulement garder 100 % de ce qu'il
produisait pour eux mêmes mais ont
bénéficié de notre générosité et de nos
exploits et donc un l'europe au sein de
ce club a une crédibilité comme garant
de multilatéralisme pendant les années
difficiles
et comme garant tout au long de la crise
de cet esprit et des actes ensuite je
pense que nous nous avons bâti dans le
cadre du g20 acta c'est une crédibilité
et ça a eu des résultats ça continuera
en avoir après nous restons des
démocraties avec la fragilité des
démocraties et c'est d'ailleurs je pense
et extraordinaire le se révèlent des
questions que nous avons aujourd'hui
tous ensemble je pense qu'il y a même
cinq ans fort sur les dix ans nous
n'aurions jamais eu un dialogue montrant
la fragilité des démocraties
occidentales à ce point on a parlé sur
la violence les réseaux en ligne
mais le propre des démocraties c'est le
peuple choisit ses dirigeants il se peut
que le peuple choisisse des dirigeants
qui ne veulent plus du multilatéralisme
et à ce moment-là ça fragilise
multilatéralisme parce que les
démocraties ont de fragilité elles
dépendent du peuple de ses choix de ses
humeurs ce qui en est une parce que là
où parfois le temps long est nécessaire
ça crée de l'instabilité plus régulière
mais je pense que c'est une richesse et
je la défends la deuxième chose c'est
que les démocraties sont dépendants
parce qu'elles sont ouvertes et donc il
n'y a d'autre possibilité que par la
coopération de maintenir nos modèles
mais je veux croire en une chose une
démocratie peut amener à sa tête des
dirigeants qui ne croient plus dans le
multilatéralisme et l'ocré où le ferais
dysfonctionné si nous ne mettant pas en
capacité comme démocratie de défendre
une concrète aux nos valeurs
dans la lutte contre la haine en ligne
nos valeurs dans la lutte contre les
inégalités de l'économie de marché pour
la fiscalité est au fond une politique
efficace
c'est pour ça que ce dont nous avons
parlé aujourd'hui est existentiel pour
nos démocraties
la plupart des problèmes auxquels nous
avons à faire face sont mondiaux aucun
pays ne peut les résoudre seul il
suppose de la coopération et donc notre
efficacité collective dans les mois et
les années qui viennent je pense
déterminera notre capacité à réussir
comme société démocratique ou pas je
pense que nos concitoyens doivent avoir
cela présente est ce sont les moments où
l'histoire se fait ou se défait notre
choix est plutôt de la faire avec
ambition avec pragmatisme parfois avec
l'esprit de résistance
toujours avec le même enthousiasme
je vais vraiment devoir voler c'est
maintenant merci beaucoup merci pour
votre attention et vos questions merci à
tous merci beaucoup et bon courage et
bientôt
non
ça